foreign
what's going on Tom was like peeking
into the next video like it usually does
because she's always like trying to get
in in the shop yeah why you haven't worn
your Starry Night shirt for a while yeah
trying to get in here
yep yeah I'm in here I'm in here are you
posing again no it's just everybody's
coming at me when you're looking like
you're pose
that's just what you look like when you
[ __ ] put on a bunch of muscle it's
like it's like my ex-wife my first wife
she was skinny as [ __ ] like olive oil
and she got those two big old [ __ ]
950cc breast implants and then wherever
she went these girls are like look at
her truck is showing off those titties
she wasn't showing them off she's just
walking around
they're the [ __ ] size of basketball
scores you're not showing them off just
the way it is the way they looked well
that's kind of they're hating on it well
the thing about it that is this kind of
thing like if you have really really big
boobs it's kind of like hard to just
exist without looking like looking like
you guys yeah you know what I mean
because a lot of clothes don't really
fit like so you look like you're trying
to be smutty even when you're not trying
to be it's just the way it is yeah
yeah it's other people reading into it
well yeah well that's right that's what
I mean that's what I mean so it's like
really hard to just like walk around
looking normal yeah like everybody's
like ooh look at her porn star I'm like
no really it's just kind of like that's
just what they look like
you can't really help it yeah
I saw a damn street interviews talking
to some of them Japanese girls and they
were [ __ ] talking about boob size
they were picking out which ones they
like it says I'd like these but
everybody would judge me
yeah like well then but then get them
that's what you want them to [ __ ]
judge you you know that's how you beat
that's how you win you know I don't
understand it but you know it's that
Wallflower mentality I I don't
understand it I'm too defiant to
understand that I do what I want to do
if you don't like it I'll probably pull
that [ __ ] up on 11. you know just let
you know [ __ ] you know what I mean
the knob goes from these don't go to ten
these go to 11.
Zach says uh I've been watching videos
of people making recipes made by AIS all
afternoon and it's hilarious AI makes
recipes yeah that's like a fun well yeah
that's kind of like what's probably
funny about it
what a good idea for uh for a YouTube
series I mean probably not a good idea
because I probably wouldn't want to eat
some of the stuff that was like produced
because I'd probably like computers
don't know what things taste like I know
well like I said that's why it's so
funny yeah that's why it's so funny okay
so
we had a good going to be a good show
today this was
um a haunting episode off of the seventh
season yeah we just kind of picked it
out random because we didn't
um because we didn't stream yesterday
because it was Christmas day hopefully
you guys had a good Christmas by the way
um so seven is actually pretty good yeah
so we didn't have like any
recommendations so we were just kind of
like going through the pile and we were
just like ah what the hell wait I don't
remember this one so let's watch this
one it actually like uh this one's
pretty good season seven is pretty good
that was the season they were
um uh a haunting still had a decent
budget you know people still kind of
watched cable television to a certain so
they were still making money I guess it
uh they upgraded the uh the the the move
the theme soundtrack you know in America
there is real evil no dudes [ __ ] just
Anthony Anthony called went like a hammy
I feel like in the later Seasons yeah
he's just like not in a bad way I'm not
saying that like to be disparaging he
put that [ __ ] up on 11. he did yeah and
it was good it was good and um
they tried their best to get to get
credible stories that had Witnesses
uh this one does have multiple Witnesses
in it a pair of brothers
the parents evidently never really saw
it I didn't believe it and then now
they've passed away
um and then this guy one of the one of
the brothers
ended up becoming a Paranormal
Investigator and uh they didn't mention
this on the show but I thought I would
mention it because I found it out
afterward when I was researching this
he's also guess what
a pretty Treacher yeah there's there is
that theme yep
um you knew which you take I didn't even
tell you you take it
for however you want to take it okay
um
so
usually and you know usually if you're a
Paranormal Investigator a preacher or or
you've written a book there's now a
monetary incentive
but
we've done that we've written books
about what happened at Mammoth Mountain
um didn't make a lot of money off of it
but that wasn't the point I was just
trying to tell the story
so it doesn't I don't discount it uh the
the best Poltergeist uh case documented
I think was like I am playfair's book
this house is haunted all right the
infield Poltergeist and a lot of people
saw that cops news reporters and stuff
so just because you have a book doesn't
mean it's fake
a lot of books are fake like to think
like the Exorcist thing that didn't
happen
this one
it could have happened it falls Within
you know certain parameters it
a lot of it kind of sounds like
Poltergeist
but then well some of it definitely does
yeah some of it sounds like some of it
doesn't
um
there could be multiple explanations of
why
um this might be something in between
Poltergeist and haunting
or it might be a poltergeist
phenomenon and certain aspects of it
were misidentified or
or the stories being mistold in certain
parts based upon people's perceptions of
what had happened
that's possible
because Lois saw that stuff at Mammoth
Mountain but
I I know she misperceived some of the
things that happened
because I saw it not and that that's not
exactly what happened but yeah that's
why she saw it
any that's with any case
even even [ __ ]
crimes that you know that happened like
shootings there'll be a bunch of
witnesses and they're all kind of
telling a slightly different story
because they all saw it happen a
different way
witness testimony is not real reliable
when it comes to details
murder Hornet said my nephew wanted me
to go to church I wore that Ouija board
shirt I'm guessing the one that we made
for our show okay nobody talked to me
yeah plus high as [ __ ] off THC Edibles
that probably helped too my nephew had
to make me leave after 15 minutes
man so judgmental yeah those churchy
people Zach says I saw a trailer for a
90s movie yesterday and I'm pretty sure
Anthony called was the narrator for it I
was like what the [ __ ] yeah I mean he's
not just I think he's best known for a
haunting maybe but he's done voice over
work for lots of other stuff he did like
some true crime shows too didn't he I
feel like like that we're on Discovery
and stuff I think he did maybe it was
was it cold case files or there was
another one like that that I used to
watch a lot that was also like the same
the same guy dude just had a good voice
well yeah is he still alive last I heard
I guess so I think he's in his 90s yeah
I mean he's got to be pretty old
but we were like we were commenting on
it last night because I mean he's got a
great voice for this kind of stuff but
it's it just did seem like they were
like can you like up the creep factor a
little bit like in these later Seasons
because it's like there's more dramatic
pauses and more like drawn out kind of
like
you know what I mean it's like a more
like that which I thought was like
really really funny in the 2000s in the
late 2000s I think he was already in his
70s yeah so he's Tom syk says I think
he's dead he's dead he might be I mean
some of the haunting episodes like I
said
um you know because it's not on anymore
right yeah didn't it go up to like
season 13 or 14 or something
you can get it you can you can order it
on Amazon but it's it's uh wasn't it
Amazon
yeah we got him on Amazon Prime you can
stream it yeah like you got to pay you
gotta pay per season because we bought
season eight
um did we ever finish that I don't think
so I don't think we ever finished and um
you never uh
you never were able to get them on DVD
they don't sell them on you know on yeah
after after about season seven or eight
they quit doing that because I guess it
just wasn't lucrative enough I guess you
know what I mean because most people
were just they weren't they they were
just buying them do you think they would
just burn them on demand like anything
else
maybe that's like not feasible I'm not
really sure yeah because I kind of feel
like that's how I mean that's how a lot
of people do their [ __ ] it's like then
that and that's good because it's like
less wasteful it only makes something
like when you yeah when somebody ordered
it
you know because I'd get them on hard on
hard copy yeah because like I said we
have up to season seven like on actual
DVDs got a whole collection of them but
yeah the first the first four seasons
came in a box set yeah because I got you
that like a while back yeah and then
every other season came in a little DVD
packet with like three discs in it
that's what yeah that's what season
seven is actually season seven was just
kind of like a little like a slightly
wider than normal DVD and it had like
that had all of them in there like that
that's where we got this from like I
said I don't even remember why we picked
this one necessarily I was just kind of
like well I know we haven't done this
one before and I said because it didn't
have like a generic sounding title
because some of the other ones were like
Echoes of the thing and just Devils of
the whatever and all that kind of stuff
but this one I was like well I know for
sure we haven't done one called the
shadow man that's for sure it's called
the shadow man we were trying to start
the show up I was remember what was the
name of this one again the black man The
Gray Man
man
this is every time seriously you guys
don't know but like but always before we
start streaming Tom never [ __ ] knows
like what we're even talking about it I
got a job yeah so it's like so it could
be a movie or something like that like
he'll literally sit down like five
minutes before the show starts what's
the show what are we talking about again
what is it who where it's like it's so
[ __ ] funny
what is this black bag Rayman yeah
he's like an old man
I am a old man
but it's just like it's funny that
you're like going like this
what what are we doing what's going on
it's always kind of like that
Zach says Shadows of the Devils of The
Echoes past pretty much it's like it
wouldn't really surprise me if one was
called because like on the disc that
this one was on there was like three
other ones that I was like well we very
well might have done some of these
because they had titles like that but I
was like well this one we definitely
haven't done and I don't remember it so
let's watch it and it was kind of good
too because it happened in Florida so I
was like oh bonus you know what I mean
not near here but it's like actually
South Florida talk about old man I
called my dad for Christmas yesterday
yeah
we were eating Christmas dinner
yesterday and he was telling me like
what his dad was saying on the phone and
I'm like oh my God you're crazy you're
[ __ ] Dad yeah Clarice who that that's
that's that's the uh
that's the black chick that lives across
the streets of the turkey necks she
calls him every day she said is it uh
Chris Clarice Ben did she bring you any
turkey necks he goes nah she called me
every day you know making sure I'm still
alive
yeah man and [ __ ] you die they don't
want you up in there stinking that house
up man yeah he's [ __ ] funny and I
told him I said
he said yeah he said you're getting big
I said yeah you know
and I told him I said I shaved my head I
shaved my head and I got a beard in the
mustaches yeah you shave your head
you're gonna have to have fish or hair
you look like a [ __ ] I was like what
what he did he said that he didn't tell
me yeah he says if you don't you look
like a [ __ ] and I said what really goes
yeah I see him on TV all the time
[Laughter]
he says you got to have facial hair
somewhere you gotta have hair on your
head or your face you can't have okay
you can't be bald and not have facial
hair he says you'll look gay
but somehow like having facial hair like
oh like I don't know like gay men can't
be bald yeah I don't yeah and yeah that
was my dad those are the rules that's my
dad's logic okay he says then exists I
see him on TV all the time
I don't know either I can't even imagine
where he might be getting that yeah my
dad's not in good health if you guys
don't know
he says all kind of crazy yeah he's only
triple bypass surgery he's got all kinds
of cancer and stuff they keep him doped
up I think pretty good and he he says
funny [ __ ] now and he's not really quite
sure what's real and what is it you know
but you know he's having fun I guess
tough psych says a dildo with ears yeah
maybe that's what it is yeah he said if
if you you shave your head and you don't
have your facial hair you will appear to
be a homosexual that's what that's the
translation that's the politically
acceptable translation of what he said
Ben says he has important insights into
our reality evidently
he sees them on TV all the time I saw it
on the TV yeah it's not on TV yeah
oh my goodness yeah you didn't even tell
me you didn't even tell me yeah yeah I
started laughing on that one you said I
forgot about that one oh okay yeah you
were telling me some other stuff about
how he was talking about like how he was
gonna die he's gonna die yeah yeah you
were telling me that like while you're
eating but
yeah I forgot everything yeah I just I
forgot exactly what he was saying just
yeah they know I'm gonna die you're just
[ __ ] funny [ __ ]
have you after you died there's nothing
it's just Oblivion that's what he said
that's right I remember Vivian
[Laughter]
I hate to say it but he does kind of
sound like you I mean you kind of sound
like that too real [ __ ] negative so
you're gonna probably get like that when
you get older no um body experiences
near death experiences I asked him
because you know it's when he fell out
of the [ __ ] hospital bed they were
[ __ ]
shocking his heart back and then he he
says I don't know why they kept shocking
me they said they were trying to bring
you back to life yeah [ __ ] that you know
[ __ ] hurt
yeah when I said did you have a
near-death experience did you see the
light not because oh hell no it ain't
nothing over there just Oblivion
I used to think you'd go to heaven Jesus
and all that now you die you just died
there's nothing there
I was like okay all right yeah yeah he
used to be Christian until he had a
near-death experience and there was
nothing there so yeah so it wasn't
really a near-death experience it was
just a death death experience
it's just Oblivion
I don't know why that's so funny to me
it's just really I'm a morbid sense of
humor I guess
but uh but yeah I just I don't know I
just find that really really funny
[ __ ] funny but that the stuff about
the facial hair that's like pretty good
yeah yeah pretty hilarious yeah
foreign
I thought see when you came at me with
that I thought he was gonna say yeah you
need facial hair because your head will
look like you know an egg or a bowling
ball or something like that so I was not
expecting no the direction that that
went because I'm just like sitting there
going
I don't understand what the connective
tissue is that was my dad's
interpretation of what you look like
when you shave your head and you don't
have any facial hair okay you appear
homosexual
okay I was like okay
I said you see it on TV all the time
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay I think he was he's on painkillers
Zach says I have both hair and facial
hair so what am I yeah I don't
understand it like I said it doesn't
make any sense at all so didn't Toby's
the biggest leather daddy in the [ __ ]
world he's got [ __ ] a whole full
beard and hair yeah
I don't know understand it I don't
understand it and he's like a [ __ ]
gorilla just [ __ ] do we actually hear
all of all of our friends that are gay
or any of them bald oh
hairy [ __ ] I can't think of one
I mean unless I'm forgetting somebody
Bears they're bears
yeah yeah I don't think we know anybody
I'm not saying there aren't any I'm just
saying that personally we don't yeah we
don't know any none of our gay friends
seem to be bald
unless I'm forgetting somebody like I
said
but uh yeah all right I think what he
was talking about what's that
because the kid they had in charge of
the nuclear waste who was wearing the
dress who did he was bald and wearing a
lipstick
you haven't seen that guy
no I'm gonna see you've been on TV
recently I don't want he got in trouble
for stealing luggage wow you've got
arrested he's a dude in a dress
that's a guy
not claiming to be a woman but he he's
bald with no facial hair
and makeup
and he steals people's luggage at the
airport
because he wanted to damn he's got a
thing for got a fetish for [ __ ]
designer luggage I mean it was all over
the news he got he lost his job
okay well like I said I wasn't really
but okay I think that's what he was
talking about maybe that's what he was I
think that's what he's talking about
because that guy looked like okay well
see that makes sense but like I said I
hadn't really seen anything about that
because you know I've been doing other
[ __ ] and I haven't really even if I had
seen like that headline I probably
wouldn't have clicked on it because yeah
whatever yeah he was in charge of like
uh some kind of nuclear waste thing he's
a federal he was a fed you know yeah
there
yeah okay feds are like that so
everybody knows what you're talking
about yeah I think I think that's what
he was talking about well I'm just
saying I hadn't like I haven't heard
about it because I want to keep it up
with it though that's all well that
explains it then yeah so it's no longer
a mystery I think that's what I did we
solved it I didn't ask I just projected
That Into You well like you said that I
mean that was really amazing that sounds
reasonable it was real mainstream and it
happened very recently so it was
probably like uppermost in his mind yeah
and his he doesn't have internet
everything is television so he's in the
television air age still which is
mind-boggling to me you know a lot of
people still are but mostly it's like
older people yeah so he doesn't really
know what's happening because it's all
propaganda on television it yeah
it's corporate propaganda
all right so
do you want to finally start talking
about a haunting or what yeah I'm ready
they're all here since we're they're
here uh 25 minutes in yeah we're 25
minutes
they're in there laughing all right so
the shadow man season seven
episode two
so the first part of this story like
most of this story I feel like it does
Jump Ahead at the end but most of the
story takes place in they just said like
the late 1960s
and this all happens in Lake Worth
Florida
which I'd heard of and they said it was
in South Florida but I wasn't sure
exactly where it was so I had to like
look it up they said it's about
um or I found it's about 64 miles north
of Miami that's where that is so
probably like several hours from here
but you know
so in the late 1960s though Lake Worth
Florida not sure about nowadays
but back then it was a pretty like
undeveloped area still and uh you know
the town was kind of developed or
established in the late 1800s they said
but it was mostly woods and [ __ ] like
that although there were some houses in
a little town there and stuff
so we're dealing with the Yancey family
and that's Yancey with ey because I had
to look that up too so the dad's name I
think they were calling him Sunny that
was his name right sunny I didn't know I
think that's what I think that's what
they were saying I didn't really noticed
the weird thing about it is that I can't
because I watched it on my laptop and I
can't for some reason I don't know if
there's uh closed captioning because I
almost always put closed captioning on
because I'm deaf as [ __ ] but um I can't
get the closed captioning to work on
these if the indeed there is any
I think we try to put closed captioning
on one of these before I don't think
there is it wasn't and there wasn't any
yeah which I was like sorry deaf people
you can't like watch the [ __ ]
um but yeah so I'm pretty sure his name
was sunny the mom's name was Barbara and
then they got two kids Tom and Tim and I
was like okay so uh Tom was the older
one and he was 12 years old and Tim was
seven like in the late 60s when this
mostly [ __ ] started happening
so they said that the house was really
kind of like isolated it was like the
end of a dirt road there didn't seem to
be any neighbors around or anything like
that
so Barbara is a stay-at-home mom like I
guess you know some of this people were
back then and sunny like Works in
construction also a Korean War veteran
that has PTSD uh that they mentioned
several times and that is one thing that
I will note about the later seasons and
this is I kind of feel like this is the
first season where I really noticed it
to any great extent is that in like from
season seven onwards they really started
repeating a lot of the information you
know what I mean like they like it would
go on and they would say this that and
the other thing and then there would be
like a commercial break even though
obviously we don't have them because
we're watching them on disc and then it
would come back and like reiterate like
a bunch of [ __ ] that they just said so
they covered a lot of the same material
like several times like I said I think I
mentioned that they mentioned that he
was like a Korean War veteran like three
or four times or and they had PTSD maybe
more than that so
they're they're less substantive is what
I'm saying like the stories were shorter
and you know there was more repeating of
the same information and showing of the
same footage over and over and I kind of
feel like season seven was when that
started so that this had a little bit of
that
so
um now apparently the dad was never the
same after he got back from the Korean
War uh they said that he was a sergeant
in what they say a mortar he ran a
mortar platoon yeah and they said that
he saw some like he saw some [ __ ] like
while he was over there and he didn't
like he never said people in Mass graves
right right that used to happen there's
a lot of you know yeah I was in Korea
for for a year I know about the Korean
War and a lot of the [ __ ] got classified
secret there were massacres between
Korean civilians and [ __ ] happening
because they were choosing different
sides and fighting over stuff and a lot
of stuff did just Whole Town's got was
slaughtered and sometimes just buried
you know he didn't really record who got
killed it was it was a that was a [ __ ]
up War
and it's forgotten people don't really
know much about it at least in the
United States
yeah I mean I do kind of feel like that
gets real short shrift you know what I
mean it's just kind of like other than
Mash they didn't really like you know
people know about that but you know most
people know a lot about World War II
people know a lot about the Vietnam War
but I kind of feel like the correct
don't they call it the Forgotten War
yeah they do yeah America got caught in
between a damn civil war between North
and South Korea
yeah the Soviets were involved I don't
even remember I don't even remember like
we learned about it in school a little
bit but I think it was just kind of like
just very very briefly like rushed over
yeah like kind of in an American history
class that's about it they spent a lot
more time on World War II and a lot more
time on Vietnam but like Korean war was
just kind of like yeah and then there
was this thing in here and blah blah
moving on you know what I mean it was
just kind of mostly forgotten in the
United States because we got our asses
kicked and they hid the fact got our
asses kicked I think that's probably why
yeah it was fought into a stalemate but
man
dumb [ __ ] happened we weren't ready for
it
but yeah so they don't really specify
like I said the only thing they specify
that this dad like saw over there was
like Mass Graves and stuff and um
according to the sons who both of them
were on here like grown up you know and
they said their dad was really like
never the same like after he came back
from there and their mom used to say
that as well
um they said he was just like got real
quick to anger and it was implied they
never came right out and said that he
was abusive
but I'm pretty sure that's what the
implication was I mean they didn't say
like oh he used to beat the [ __ ] out of
us or anything like that they portrayed
him on the show like the actor who went
a little bit over the top gonna have to
say
um but they portrayed him on the show as
being like a real dick you know what I
mean like he was all like always like
yelling at them like where is that
raccoon kind of like he was a discipline
kind of level yeah but it was just kind
of it was like that
but
I don't know if he like smacked him
around or stuff like that they didn't
say that but that was kind of like the
implication because the particular
summer that all of this stuff happened
they said that he was seemed like he was
getting way worse and one of the
brothers actually described him as the
word that he used was wicked so you know
so I'm assuming that he probably like
beat the crap out of them but they don't
really say that
now our narrator friend Anthony call
says that whatever was affecting the dad
seemed to be coming from the woods
but it wasn't really specified how they
knew that exactly
I also don't think it was ever mentioned
like how long the family had been living
here like presumably without any
problems look at it Pookie is like this
I saw a Spock moving around so that's a
molesting mirror spot
she's like but I love him
just a beard
it's just funny how sometimes you see
Spock like you know like that in the
background it's not ghosts it's just
like a little bit of kitties you can't
you can't really see her but yeah so I
don't really know
they didn't really say did they like how
long this had been going on at this
house like or how long they'd been
living there I mean because I presume
they had been living there before and
like nothing bad had happened it moved
no they moved in there when they were
like six seven eight around that time I
know they left when they were 10 years
no no no no no no no no no no I just
watched it a couple hours ago they
didn't just move there oh I thought I
thought they moved in there they were
already grown
no that was later
that was later
what are you talking about you talking
about the house right with the woods
yeah didn't they buy that house and move
into it
later when they were grown up one of
them did they weren't born in that house
I don't think yeah but what I was saying
was that I don't think that they
mentioned how long they'd been living
there before they said it was the late
60s one of them was 12 one of them was
seven yeah but they didn't say that they
just moved there and I'm assuming or
they wouldn't have [ __ ] told the
story that way
but they didn't say that they had just
moved there and normally they would like
because that happens a lot like because
on the show it's pretty much always hey
we moved to this new house and then
[ __ ] up [ __ ] started happening so if
they just moved to this place I thought
that they would have mentioned it but
they didn't so I just assumed that
they'd been at this house that they were
born in that house well I didn't say
that they were necessarily born in it
but I'm just saying they're born in the
hospital
no I'm just saying that they had lived
in it for some time before that like
before this stuff started happening yeah
I don't know the details because they
didn't well that's what I was saying it
was like they didn't really say it like
the way they're telling the story is
that they were saying they had this
house out there and it was uh at the
edge of a dirt road and it was a they're
showing a big old nice house you know
uh and and this is this is uh this is
happening in a time before Florida was
really built up like it is now
so it'd be like having a [ __ ]
mansion on the end of at the edge of a
swap all right and it actually is yeah
and they were afraid of the [ __ ]
Woods
all right and they were going out there
and they were seeing things in the woods
like an invisible forces yeah we'll get
it things up in the trees
just the way the story is being shown
and the way they're telling the story
I was led to believe that they hadn't
been living there for very long when
they were going out into those woods
because they weren't used to it but I
will note that their dad which they do
mention on the show their dad built them
a fort out there they had a fort out
there that they played in and they said
they played out there all the time yeah
so I'm just assuming that they've been
there for a while like before the scary
[ __ ] started happening maybe it wasn't
like they just moved there you know what
I mean yeah that's all I'm saying I
didn't I wasn't implying that they'd
been born there they didn't say that I
was just saying that the show didn't
specify how long they'd been living
there but I just assumed that they
hadn't just moved there because they
would have mentioned that because they
normally would mention that
Tom Sykes says is this episode anywhere
near you guys or that other episode
titled The Haunting in Florida anywhere
near that area Florida is is near us I'm
friends with I'm friends with that guy
this episode
um not that near us this is actually
like about 60 odd miles north of Miami
uh Miami is probably about what four
hours from here something like that
um maybe farther maybe five hours I
can't really remember but four or five
hours from here The Haunting in Florida
that took place in Deltona which um
right over there that is actually
Deltona was only about 20 30 miles from
where I was born and where I grew up
like most of my life and I've been to
Deltona Lake many many times yeah and I
went to Ace Hardware one day
right right there near our house and was
having a guy pick out fasteners for me I
was looking for [ __ ] Fasteners and
bolts for for the for my Buell they had
to be machine quality and I'm looking at
it and I'm going man you're at Dunham
he's like yeah
is it from how hot he goes yeah you saw
Michelle
Ed he was just working at the Ace
Hardware like right up the street from
our old house and I was uh
calling him on the phone and talked to
him over uh Facebook for a while and
then he kind of became a justice of the
peace and he'll dress up like a harvey
Ranger and marry you because he is an
army ex-army Raider it was what he was
from uh one of the bad he was a bad boy
he was he was uh from uh 75th infantry
Ranger regiment
but um
yeah so and I've been to that house
haven't been in it but I've been outside
and saw it I didn't get any feelings off
of it though
yeah we figured out where it was yeah I
know where it is I've never been to that
neighborhood but I've been to Deltona
before yeah in that episode they'll show
a nice house and and they kind of make
you they use it as an establishing shot
that house is on that block but it's not
that house yeah
that's what I mean it's about four
houses down I always kind of wonder if
they do if they routinely do that it's
like if they will find a house that says
near to the actual house as possible
you know what I mean
because in that case like you said you
saw the one that they used to shoot the
show and it's not the actual house but
it's on the same block right no the one
they should they use the house to shoot
the episode
I don't know where that house was that
is not the house that he was in
they used a house on that block for as
an establishing shot yeah but it's not
that house it's about four houses down
from that house
all right the one that Ed was in wasn't
that impressive
it wasn't as nice as the one that they
used as the establishment yeah I mean I
guess they're usually going to use one
that looks a little bit more cinematic
yeah I mean I mean it's a nice house but
it wasn't that nice right I gotcha
but yeah so to answer your question The
Haunting in Florida house is pretty near
not so much anymore it was actually
nearer to our old house like in Sanford
and actually it was only like I said 20
30 miles from where I grew up because I
grew up in Daytona Beach
um but the one in this one is pretty far
it's probably like four-ish hours from
here
because it's way down in South Florida
and Florida is really big
so you know
um all right so this area like I said it
wasn't really built up at the time it's
probably like way more built up now like
being 60 odd miles from Miami I'm sure
that I mean that whole area is just like
all big [ __ ] sprawl at this point
so um but back then this area was still
a refuge well it had been like back in
the old days like a refuge for escape
slaves like during the Civil War and
like after that and um also Native
Americans escaping from these Seminole
Wars like running away from that uh so
all of the place like back then was
still a lot of it was like swamps and
woods and [ __ ]
now so some of these Woods still butted
up against the Yancey's property like I
said it didn't look like there was any
other houses around
so the boys were really into like
playing in the woods uh around their
house and they said it was about two or
three square miles like the you know the
section of woods where they played all
the time so their dad had built them
this little fort out there I don't know
what it looked like in real life it just
looked kind of like a little weird Shack
like in Friday the 13th
um like in the in the reenactment but I
don't know what it looked like in real
life so and they said that they had made
little paths out there that they would
use like I said that's what made me
think that they probably lived there for
a little while like before the scary
[ __ ] started happening because you know
they had time to like build a fort and
paths and [ __ ] like that
so one day they're out in the woods
playing like usual and Tom the older one
he's kind of outside the fort and the
younger kid goes down to like the pond
to go fishing or something like that
so Tom thinks he hears not you but like
you know the kid Tom uh he uh is outside
the fort he thinks he hears somebody's
footsteps like little Twigs breaking and
[ __ ] like that
so he said he got the feeling he's being
watched but he's like looking around and
he doesn't see anybody
so he goes into the four Jack thing
and then like a creepy shadow of a man
like passes by the windows they weren't
like real windows but they were just
kind of like cut with little like
curtains on them or whatever they didn't
have glass in them it didn't look like
and he hears like more kind of rustling
and footsteps and [ __ ] now he said he's
like well I didn't know what it was
um and he says this he said these words
he said I didn't know maybe it was a
monster or something that's what he said
so he knew that it wasn't a person you
know what I'm saying
um but he says I'm not gonna tell
anybody about it he didn't tell anybody
about it meanwhile Tim the younger
brother who has gone down to go fishing
or whatever he starts hearing some
noises too like somebody walking around
like breaking sticks and whatnot and
essentially he sees I was like so he saw
the Predator is is what he saw yeah he
saw the Predator looked like an
invisible man that's what they showed
yeah I don't know if that's exactly what
he saw but I was like it looked like he
did it was like the Predator I think
they might have taken Liberties because
he didn't come out and say that but
I mean he did say that he that he saw
like she had to be figures uh like and
it well no like at this point he said
he's he couldn't see the thing but he
saw how it reacted or how the um
disturbing the disturbing the object so
he said he saw it climbing down the tree
like he saw it up in the trees and then
like climbing down the tree and like
landing on the ground and he did
specifically say that he couldn't see
the actual thing it's just how like the
objects were like reacted to it yeah so
at this point it wasn't the bark moving
and the [ __ ] moving out of the way right
right right you know okay there's a lot
of stuff that can do that give that well
yeah I've seen [ __ ] squirrels run up
and down trees so fast sometimes you
just see the disturbance you don't see
the squirrel
they're gray sometimes they just bled
right into bark too yeah and the
lighting's right but I'm not saying you
know I'm not calling a guy a liar that's
just the way he remembered it yeah and I
mean he was seven you're seven right I
don't remember [ __ ] from when I was
seven years yeah I can remember stuff
you know what I mean yeah not really
right uh so yeah so he then he kind of
hears like twigs and branches like
breaking behind him and he's you know in
the show they showed him like freaking
out or running out of the woods and uh
he tells his mom about it but the mom is
like oh it was probably just an animal
on tries to like calm him down or
whatever
so after that they apparently start
seeing these shadow men or with just one
shadow man we're not really sure moving
around outside the house and in the
woods apparently on more than one
occasion like the way they talked about
it
and um although they were pretty scared
they decided like they're not going to
tell their parents they didn't want to
talk about it too much because they
thought if we talked about it too much
like it would make it worse or like
summon the thing you know what I mean
so one night Tim the younger brother
like both the brothers like slept in the
same room right so he wakes up in the
middle of the night and he said that he
felt a presence in the room
so he sees a shadow that looks like a
person
go past the window like outside so he
gets up and looks out but like nothing's
there
so then he kind of goes back to bed and
then he sees the thing again now he
tries to wake up his brother but I guess
his brother was like man like leave me
alone and he doesn't wake up so then he
goes back to the window and looks out
and then he sees like a shadow man like
obviously like standing in the yard and
he just like screams his head off and I
laughed like
I laughed at the kids screaming because
they showed it like two or three times
like they repeated it it was super funny
just I don't know why that kid's
screaming like made me laugh so much
but I'm gonna tell them [ __ ] tell them
about I'm gonna try this out I gave it
to Jenny yeah this is this is one of my
Christmas presents Midnight Moon
strawberry strawberry moonshine with an
actual real strawberries in it we're
gonna see what it's like
I mean we've had that we've had the
Midnight Moon
apple pie right uh no it was another
brand oh that was another brand that's
right yeah that's right that was old
smokey old smokey we've had other brands
of that though that's right
okay I'm still drinking my vodka it's
okay oh my God it smells good yeah
oh man that's good
it's real tart powerful
it's very very strong but it's really
good like the flavor of it's really nice
real dry no yeah yeah you probably
wouldn't be able to drink like if you
drink yeah I know I smelled it already
um
[Laughter]
I feel like if I drank a lot of it I
would probably like throw it yeah
because because it's like real dry
[ __ ] up on this but it's very very
strong it's good though that's like a
good flavor yeah that's a very good it's
mellowing out yeah okay
Yeah Tim says moonshine that's a swig of
the good stuff it is good that's very
good
I mean that that is good that's um
what's that brand called Midnight Moon
yeah this is a good brand and um old
smokey is a good brand too yeah old
smokey I think we have the apple pie one
and we had the butter pecan one yeah
butter pecan was light that was kind of
like uh Bailey's Irish Cream that tasted
almost exactly like baby yeah Irish
cream right Zach says what is the appeal
of moonshine again I've never tried it
power
yeah
very powerful [ __ ] it is yeah
and Zach says uh or Ben said uh Zach you
make it yourself so it's free yeah well
that's that's free that was twenty
dollars
it's good though but that's like Artisan
that's like Artisan moonshine
although you can buy that pretty much
anywhere nowadays like I kind of feel
like even the little uh little bitty
liquor store down by our republics has
some flavors
Tammy says we were doing shots of root
beer moonshine yesterday that sounds
good Sugar Land brand oh yeah I would
drink the hell out of it yeah we'll have
to look for that this it's mainly that
brand an old smokey that I see around at
the liquor stores around here but ABC we
have an ABC Liquor not too far from here
they might have Sugar Land we'll have to
look because that sounds actually good
moonshine similar to Everclear
you got to be careful you know I don't
know what proof that is but does it mean
it's usually [ __ ] this is this is
probably it's not pure moonshine of
course
um
I don't know I can't see it you keep
moving it
let's say 50.
100 100 100 Proof
100 Proof
I think 200 is pure isn't it I have no
idea yeah
Ben says Artisan moonshine like homeless
Chic pretty much yeah it is kind of like
that that's good though pretty good
are you gonna eat one of the
strawberries they're down the bottom
all right so uh so where was I oh okay
so the kid looks out the window and sees
the shadow man standing out in the yard
and just like screams his head off and I
laughed at the kid I mean that kid
screaming was pretty funny
I'm not saying that like the kid was
like yeah
I don't know I can't do it but it was
like super funny I don't know why I
thought it was so funny uh so yeah so
his dad comes running but of course his
dad is like a real jerk about it
um Tim says hey there's a man outside
and that's like crying out loud
and then like he goes he does go outside
to check like to his credit but of
course there's nobody out there
so two weeks later they specify the
older brother Tom he said he started
acting real weird like sleepwalking
pretty much every night this was like
pretty freaky actually yeah
um and he would kind of like wander out
the house and down to like a pond that
was like on their property and like he
would just kind of like stand there like
looking into the pond
um the younger brother Tim said it
seemed like something was drawing him
out there but he would do it like pretty
much every night he would just like get
up and like walk out the house and then
they like find him out in the [ __ ]
Woods so they said that Tom actually
sleepwalked for weeks and he talked
about like how freaky it was to wake up
and be outside with like no memory of
how he got there I'm like yeah looking
at the pond looking at the pot that
would be oh my God it happened to me I
would talk about it on the show not too
long ago that's pretty scary I don't
think I've ever sleepwalked in my whole
entire life yeah now that I've done it a
couple now that I've brought it up yeah
um you know I probably will but I've
never had that happen I've only done it
a couple times
would you would you would you count that
one that one time a couple months ago
that was kind of like sleepwalking yeah
that was one that's the only other I can
only remembered only a couple other
times it was when I was a kid
yeah waking up instead in front of the
refrigerator
going what am I doing like I was gonna
get something to eat yeah yeah well
that's what you were thinking about well
I mean that's good because I kind of
feel like to me that seems really scary
because it's just kind of like who
[ __ ] knows what you're gonna do like
when you're walking around you could
like [ __ ] I could sleep walk and I
could like fall down the [ __ ] stairs
and break my neck and some [ __ ] like
that you know what I mean
that would that would be bad
you know what you're doing
when you're when you're sleepwalking
basically Kinda Yeah you have normal
dexterity
you just walk downstairs well that makes
me feel better yeah I've never had like
you'd walk off into off like walk off a
cliff or something
see that's what I always thought no
because I just always thought it was
like dreaming with your eyes open so
it's like if you were dreaming about
no you're interacting with the world
okay
just saying so uh so yeah so but he but
this kid said he didn't really remember
it like he would just kind of be he
would wake up and then he'd be outside
like standing looking out the pond you
know what I mean so since this kid kept
get getting up every night essentially
and like waking the dad up because like
the dad is just kind of like look I
gotta work in the morning remember which
you know I get it like you know what I
mean
um so the mom and dad
perhaps not all that wisely but I kind
of feel like maybe they couldn't think
of anything else to do so they decide
they're gonna like essentially barricade
the kids in their bedroom so they took
like these chairs and like piled them in
front of the door and then like tied the
chairs like to the doorknob like from
outside so they wouldn't be able to get
out so I was like so now the kids are
[ __ ] if like the house catch is on
fire or they couldn't even get out to go
to the bathroom which
gross but okay
so yeah they just like I said they
didn't really know what else to do
so so they do that but what ends up
happening is that the older kid Tom he
gets up and goes to the door like normal
like he's sleepwalking
and he tries to get out but he can't get
out
so his younger brother woke up and saw
him and said he was just standing there
just like working at the
doorknob like trying to get out and it
said he didn't seem like he was getting
mad or frustrated or nothing it's just
like he stood there for ages and was
just going like did it like he was
trying to get out and he's like I mean
that would be really creepy like if I
woke up and saw that
um so then though Tim is like Darren
trying to pretended like I was gonna
take a piss thought I was gonna take a
piss
standing there for a long time
yeah see I don't know like I said I
don't know how long you were standing
because I just I just woke up you
weren't making any noise or anything but
I guess I just sensed you standing there
because I woke up and then I saw you and
I was like what are you doing I said I'm
taking a piss and I was like are you
peeing on the floor and I was like yeah
but I wasn't I was just standing there I
thought I was I thought I was taking a
leak into her bathroom yeah [ __ ]
funny you were real drunk though I mean
that that was like I was dead drunk at
that time well no but I mean that was
after after a night of him drinking
that's yeah that's why yeah so maybe
that's why brain working for work not
wasn't working right he got some wires
Crossing
Tim says as a sleepwalker I take
medication for it now but until me and
my doctor figured it out I had some
bizarre occurrences see I always thought
I've never had it happen to me so I
don't really know but it's like it
always seemed like really scary to me so
I don't know you know what I mean
because I don't know like how aware you
are stuff but um yeah so
so Tom can't get out of the room
and then Tim is like standing there
looking at him like would you like stop
right on the doorknob like dad's gonna
wake up and he's gonna like beat her
asses or whatever
and then Tim said the closet door like
the um the doorknob on the closet door
started to Rattle and then the closet
door he said open by itself
and Tom still sleepwalking very calmly
went over and went into the closet and
then sat down on the floor of the closet
and then the door shut by itself yeah
that's what he saw that happen he said
yeah he said he saw that happen and then
he said that I heard two voices coming
from behind the door like two top two
voices like talking in the closet he's
like okay I returned Tom's boys and one
other voice and they were like having a
conversation in there see I was thinking
up until this point watching the
watching the episode that this is
actually kind of in general going along
the same kind of Arc as as Poltergeist
phenomena and rspk they got
a house in turmoil kids the right age a
bunch of stress
um uh the disciplinarian father who
won't let them act out any of this stuff
so that there's a lot of frustration and
the [ __ ] goes [ __ ] rspk recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis under the
control of one of those boys
subconscious
and a lot of the phenomena is being
described so far sounds like Poltergeist
later it changes but you know
but the whole thing about seeing the
door open and him walk in there and sit
down in the door closed voucher guys
could do that
and it's happening why he's sleepwalking
so he's in an altered state of
consciousness
so yeah it just kind of fits with
Poltergeist
yeah pretty weird yeah Tom Sykes says
like a victim of the Blair Witch
standing in the corner type [ __ ] yeah I
think that's what like kind of freaks me
out about it I don't like I don't know
like little things like that like creep
me out more than like big things you
know what I mean so it's like if I woke
up and saw somebody sleepwalking like
trying to get out and then they just
stood there and like kept trying to get
out and they didn't get mad or
frustrated or nothing they just like
stood there and did that that would
freak me out a lot so yeah and and them
just like describing it kind of freaked
me out a little bit his brain's not
working right right you sleepwalk
kind of like glitching out
then he says is sleepwalking rape still
rape well I guess the victim you could
do it well I guess I'm the victim but
the other end there's they still are
raped so yeah I guess it would still
count
even if you didn't mean it
uh block frog said I wanted to mention I
thought of Tom today because I listened
to Labyrinth by David Bowie oh yeah you
were looking at them pants everybody's
looking at it
hahaha
Tim said while he was sleepwalking I
poured cat litter in the toilet and it
clogged the drain have no memory of it
damn and I lost my shoe did you ever
find it yeah well I think he lost the
shoe
that's right I need more information
about that he said he lost it so he
never found it that's what I'm saying
yeah Tammy said who was the man that
killed his wife and said he did it while
sleepwalking oh that's right there was a
case like that holy [ __ ] now we need to
do a show about that kind of [ __ ]
it's like I don't know like a likely
story I kind of feel like well it's
possible maybe it it's possible but I'm
just saying that it's like there's
nobody there wouldn't be any Randall
like um you know kind of back that up or
corroborate that
thank you Katie
Mary belated Christmas from Pat and Cat
thanks for being the best podcast on the
net thank you thank you very much that's
really awesome Merry Christmas hope you
guys had a good one yeah
um okay let me see oh okay so he's in
the closet right and uh Tim is just like
here he's like I could hear them talking
in there and he was like wigging out
he's seven right so he's like wigging
out
so Tim starts yelling for his mom not
for his dad because he knows his dad's
gonna yell but his parents both come
running so Tim is just like terrified
they're like where's your brother
where's Tommy and Tim's like
point to the [ __ ] closet he said
there
so the mom opens the closet and Tom is
just sitting there on the floor and
she's like what are you doing and he
says there's a man in here with me at
which point if that was my kid I'd be
like nope nope nope that's like that's
creepy
um and Tom said later that he was sure
that he saw like a shadow figure sitting
across from him in the closet that had
like red eyes looking at him
so um yeah she kept saying and she's
like there look there's no dude in there
and you're just [ __ ] around so get
the [ __ ] out of here you're like keeping
us awake
and you know of course they don't
believe him because why would you
so here's another thing that you were
saying was very poltergeisty
so one night sometime later a bunch of
like random [ __ ] from outside starts
falling into Tim's bed while he's
sleeping out of nowhere so yeah it was
like it was like rocks and like pine
cones roaches yeah yeah they had well he
said like roaches from Florida but they
actually showed like Madagascar hitching
his hissing cockroaches but they did
have some like Florida cockroaches mixed
in there too I saw it yeah objects from
outside falling out of nowhere
um is uh usually rocks and things like
that that's Poltergeist that's a common
Poltergeist phenomenon thing
it's weird but also having [ __ ]
roaches that's common [ __ ] Florida
yeah I was like if it had just been the
roaches that have been like welcome to
Florida yeah
yep [ __ ] uh they will get inside your
house and come ride it through the doors
the sliding glass doors they get in and
um it doesn't matter how clean your
house is they they smell food [ __ ] a
mile away they try to get in so it's
just
as long as long as you don't get the
infestation you leave out poisons and
[ __ ] you can stay on top of it but it's
not as bad as it was I've noticed in the
past 10 years
it seems like because it's grown up more
you know what I mean there's population
densities got a little bit increased
they're making more houses it seems like
people have to share the Cockroaches now
because I don't have as many you don't
have as many well and a lot of people
have like Pest Control Pest Control
right I know what I mean so there's like
fewer places for the bugs but in the
days that they're talking about it would
have been a lot worse
well when I was growing up like it was
pretty common to like wake up in the
middle of the night and hear like roach
like a roach or two like skittering
around your wall or like feel it like
dropping on yourself yeah they're really
big the size of a mouse and they're
[ __ ] running around outside the house
I had that happen I had one fall on my
chest once well like a flying one like
follow my chest like that while I was
sleeping I had one
um I put on a shirt that was in my
closet and one kind of like came out of
the pocket yeah I had that happen
um I had one uh I put on a shoe and it
pulled and then it came out over my foot
like I had that happen more than once
the whole 12 years I've been living in
Florida I've only had two roaches get me
and it was within a month from of each
other I was in bed next to Jenny and
woke up [ __ ] one of them was running
across my chest and I [ __ ] grabbed
him [ __ ] threw him oh I remember that
remember that yeah
and then like about a month or so later
I woke up in the morning and rolled over
to go get a drink of Coca-Cola because I
left a Coca-Cola inside the bed and
looked in there as a big old [ __ ]
palmetto bug down in there I was like oh
[ __ ]
palmetto bugs
the good thing about it is is that the
big palmetto bug Florida Florida
cockroaches
they really can't infest your house
well they live outside they live in
palmetto trees
they're too big to really infest your
house because you see them right off
and uh you jump on them and kill them
and the cats kill them so they never
really get a [ __ ] foothold Beijing
will tear them up yeah you'll find
pieces like sometimes we find pieces
Pookie though is grossed out by them
like she calls for help and smacks them
and holds them down and ah come get it
but she's like kind of she's grossed out
but she doesn't really want to touch it
yeah so but Beijing doesn't care she
will just like pick it up and like tear
so we find like little pieces like
little lids and stuff so you never
really get any kind of infestations and
then like in the past 11 years we had
one infestation but it only lasted
really a couple days and then just got
them with [ __ ] smoke with the [ __ ]
bug bombs and it was uh it's the little
bitty German yeah German cockroach and
they
what they tend to do is they get in the
house
and they do things like get up
underneath your damn uh dishwasher or
your oven or your oven uh dishwasher is
mostly because half the day you got
dirty dishes in there waiting to fill up
the dishwasher well they come
out from the top the dishwasher go in
through the cracked door because you
usually people had the door cracked they
go in there and go get him something to
eat yeah and then they go back and hide
and you don't know you really have them
until it's too late yeah first time you
see a dead little [ __ ]
they're little all right as soon as you
see a little dead little cockroach in
the bottom of your dishwasher
pull that dishwasher out
it's bolted in pull it out and look I
mean but you might already in there you
might want to put a hazmat suit on
before you do that
yeah because you're gonna have a bad
time
put a bug bomb right there and [ __ ]
you'll get them all
and then you put down the dam
uh traps they're like a little poison
traps they're like little food and
they'll go down and eat that and die as
long as you stay on top of them you
won't really get an infestation just
keep your eye yeah we just had one
happen briefly and that was German
cockroaches German cockroaches yeah they
weren't even from here they're from
Germany
I don't think they're [ __ ] immigrants
I don't know why I think I you know what
I just blame the Germans I used to know
like why they were called that but I
don't know if that's where they kind of
like I thought they came over on a ship
from Germany or something maybe they did
yeah but I don't know if that's where
they are we live here now
well yeah they everywhere and even
places where it's too cold for like big
ass roaches like we have down here like
yeah we'll still have German cockroaches
yeah because I kind of feel like up
north they don't see the like the really
big ones like we have down here yeah
they don't because New York's got them
big ones they live in the do they live
in the [ __ ] well yeah they've like
the Subways in the soup but like I said
they can't really like live where it's
super super cold all the time so if
they're somewhere like that's a big city
that has places that's warm like the
Subways and stuff yeah you can live down
there yeah but get down to the pipes and
[ __ ] they'll live in some of those
buildings in New York are just [ __ ]
fasted just crazy infested saw programs
on them
[ __ ] where they had to condemn damn
near condemn the entire [ __ ] Skies
the whole [ __ ] building and it's
almost like a skyscraper just
because it was built a long time ago and
there were places for those roaches to
go and they're getting once they're in
it and never coming out and the thing
about it is that like as big as those
roaches are they can like squish
themselves down like super super flat
yeah and so they can get in places that
you would I have seen one of them
that was like that like smushed himself
down and get into this teeny teeny like
paper thin crack like uh like between
the cabinet yeah
yeah it's them it's the most [ __ ] up
thing you've ever seen they can just
like hybrid like that like they can make
themselves like a piece of paper and
they're not quiet you hear those
[ __ ] stomping around
yeah
like I said I used to hear that
sometimes growing up like you'd wake up
in the middle of the night here like
their [ __ ] legs
like crawling across the wall and I'd be
like oh no and there's [ __ ] spiders
here that big I haven't seen one in a
while but when I was at the bar in
[ __ ] 10 years ago those things were
[ __ ] just infested that damn bar and
living up in the roof of the barn yeah
my grandpa there's a big there's they're
a hunting spider that's bigger than a
tarantula they're not as they don't
weigh with a tarantula they're not
venomous though but they're splayed out
about that big gray yeah and they run
and they'd run across the top of the
feed bags and you can hear them
like the damn thing from Alien you know
the [ __ ] face sucker they're like
that
look man man Wicked
didn't like him I didn't like them at
all I had Tom doesn't like spiders I
kicked one of them one time it was up on
the wall of a stall and I kicked it and
it popped and it's ass juice [ __ ] hit
me in the face man oh man spider ass oh
so gross yeah nasty
they're the size of a mouse man yeah
yeah
I've seen some ones that size like in my
grandpa's old house yeah a long time ago
although there's less of them now I
guess people have wiped them out in this
area
yeah like I said because everybody uses
pesticides yeah and there's more houses
now so it's just it's beating them back
another thing that I found up here when
I was this that was the part I'm talking
about three miles from here it's near
the biker bar yeah and uh
nothing I found myself cleaning out
stalls and [ __ ] doing setting up
setting up the bar for the day a [ __ ]
coral snake
yeah I got a king snake of course yeah I
saw one actually I had a coral snake go
across my foot one time at my grandma's
house well I was walking down the back
steps and it just went yeah and it was
little it wasn't very big and very
docile they don't get very big yeah of
course if it was little and it was
docile but they're very venomous I
picked it up yeah they don't bite though
unless you [ __ ] with him yeah I picked
it up yeah I had gloves on well I picked
it yeah I had big heavy gloves on I
picked it up patted him a little bit
with the gloves and then took him out
and let him go I don't kill snakes just
because they're poisonous they don't
they can't help it
it's not their fault and you shouldn't
because they actually like other [ __ ] to
do well they keep down uh other like you
know Roto populations and things like
that
I mean I try not to kill anything other
than broaches [ __ ] [ __ ] roaches but all
that Rattlers go
yeah let him go because they always warn
they always warn you before they bite
you yeah they don't like to bite
it's a waste of Venom it takes a lot of
calories for them to generate Venom and
they use that to hunt
my dad got bit by a diamondback
rattlesnake in California
and he didn't even tell anybody he got
bit he didn't he was kind of embarrassed
of it and um and it's because it was a
dry bite
it was just a warning a warning like hey
like yeah it said it's it's set it's
sent it put the [ __ ] in him but it
didn't send any [ __ ] Venom into it
yeah said it was about like a bee sting
said it knew it he knew as soon as it
happened that it was a dry bite
he said he could tell
that he didn't get vandomized it burned
a little bit but it was like a and it
didn't swell up and he knew the symptoms
it didn't swell up immediately yeah
because you know if you know immediately
well the thing about like I said the
snakes are
people are scared of snakes but they're
like way more scared of you I mean
you're way bigger than them
and can step on them and you have
weapons and stuff so it's just kind of
like
really the only time like people do get
bit here but the only way that you get
bit is if you [ __ ] with them like if
you're trying to pick them up or
sometimes um I've heard of people
getting bit like when they were just
like gardening and like they reached a
hand without looking like into a bush
and there happened to be a snake in
there it doesn't happen that's why my
dad didn't want to tell anybody he was
[ __ ] with it he tried to catch it
see that's why not like 95 of the people
that get bit they were trying to catch
the snake you're trying to catch it
and he was going to take he was going to
take it back home and keep it in the
[ __ ] a terrarium yeah
that was his idea he was young you know
at the time and I was with him but I was
about five I remember it though
and uh he didn't want my mom to know
yeah yeah
but that wouldn't happen if he got
killed and I was out there
understandable yeah
yeah doing something dumb like that so
he didn't say anything well if dudes
would quit doing dumb [ __ ] then you
wouldn't have to like keep [ __ ] like
that a secret you just stop doing dumb
[ __ ] problem solved he was trying to
catch
big old [ __ ] California Diamondback
yeah Zach says Florida is the Australia
of America it is yeah kind of it is in a
lot of ways
I mean we don't I don't think we have as
many poisonous or venomous things as
Australia does but
you know
but it's kind of it's kind of bad it
goes all the way to the Panhandle all
the way to New Orleans Louisiana it's
all like it's all similar
anything along the Gulf Coast
both coasts actually you go up to the
Atlantic coast up inside Florida it's
like that to Pirate Land
you know the South it's all the South
Tammy says Jenny that guy's name with
the Sleepwalker murder uh is Scott
flatter fallatter for later I'm not
really sure for later for later that's
that's probably not the way he wants it
pronounced
um
he stabbed and drowned his wife back in
1997. stabbed and drowned and he claimed
he was sleepwalking hmm
I don't know I'm not buying it
Ben says Queensland is the Florida
Australia
yeah Florida is the Florida of Florida I
mean I I don't think we have as many
um killer animals as Australia does but
[ __ ] if you introduce it into the wild
it'll it'll blend right in though so you
never know what you're gonna find around
here because [ __ ] man we could
somebody's like [ __ ] Tiger King or
somebody like that could like [ __ ]
one of their Tigers could get away and
they'd be like hey it's kind of nice out
here in the [ __ ] swamps
and then he sees like there's a little
population of tigers out there you know
it happens
but you know we got snakes and
alligators we got a tiger King up a road
here we do yeah
it's not not the Tiger but it's just one
of those kind of one of those guys the
tiger guys yeah he's about uh two three
miles from here he's got a big old
compound and it's got a big [ __ ] wall
around it
um my mom knows him
he was uh some kind of a an actor at one
time he think he was one of the dudes
that played Tarzan he's an old man now
he was he's like one of the tarzans or
some [ __ ] like that but he's got a whole
bunch of [ __ ] big cats
and an elephant and I think he's got
some giraffes he's got a African stuff
back there
Camp guy said I would imagine it is
legal to kill pythons in Florida
is it
probably you can kill anything here at
that yeah I'm not really sure I mean
even it's not a game even alligators it
was illegal to kill alligators for a
while because they were endangered but I
think they've been taken off the
endangered list so you can you know I
wouldn't advise it but you can
I don't know about pythons I imagine you
probably could because pythons are an
invasive species a lot of people keep
them as and I love python so I'm not
going to get like all you know I I
wouldn't kill one I think they're cool
but um a lot of people kept them as pets
and you know so inevitably escaped yeah
uh so a lot of them live in the wild now
uh so you know we have we have them in
the wild there's all kinds of stuff here
there's arapaima that's what I don't
belong here that's what I'm saying it's
just kind of like there's a I kind of
feel like Florida has so many invasive
species and it's like not even invasive
species anymore you release anything
into the wild in Florida it's pretty
much gonna Thrive because this is like a
[ __ ] swampy
yeah which is a [ __ ] big [ __ ] rat
swamp rat
for all I know there's capybara here
it's only a matter of time before
probably before capybara make it here
honestly seeing anything wouldn't
surprise me yeah in the in this people
keep copy borrows pets so it wouldn't
wouldn't surprise me that some of them
[ __ ] get out yeah they're funny
it's like it's a [ __ ] groundhog the
size of a dog yeah like a big ass yeah
and if they'll chase you and play games
and [ __ ] they're crazy
jump in the water after you
Tammy says iguanas yeah
iguanas too we got tons of iguanas out
in the wild because a lot of people keep
those as pets I used to have one as a
pet when um Liz there's all different
kinds of lizards chameleons yeah we got
all kind of different kinds of geckos
yep I used to have a gecko nice out big
salamander big black salamanders [ __ ]
red stripes on them Stripes yeah
everything
bear
there's a big cat here
um Bobcats and [ __ ] we got Panthers also
Panthers yeah
they're endangered but you see them from
time to time yeah I've seen bobcats in
the wild before I saw one um several
years ago like in the woods I had a
little strip of woods by my house
but I'll be in the neighborhoods they
were at Dr Matt's house all the time
yeah that's what I mean I lived in like
just a regular ass like Suburban
neighborhood and I saw Bobcat more than
once like just chilling through the
backyard they'll jump in and try to [ __ ]
the house cats yeah people don't realize
that they can crossbreed yeah they're a
little rapist male rapist well all cat
sex is rape anyway well pretty much Tom
Sykes or at least they're pretending
it's rape baby cats will have rape
fantasies yeah yeah how did we get here
I kind of I I feel like I think that at
least once a show role-playing
top sex says skunk Apes yeah we probably
got skunk Apes too
and I kind of well most of it is kind of
is because of um the Everglades because
man that's all there's all kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] going on down there we
gonna finish the show Jim we gotta talk
about these ghosts yeah all right let's
think about this topic all right we'll
talk about this afterwards so okay so we
were talking about yeah yeah so all the
random [ __ ] we gotta we got distracted
by roaches yeah yeah because there were
roaches falling in this kid's bed which
uh yeah I don't like that like [ __ ] that
ghost don't be dropping roaches in my
bed
um so yeah so rocks and [ __ ] so he calls
his mom now see I thought because I
didn't remember this episode
I thought when his mom came in to see
what he was yelling about that all the
[ __ ] was going to be gone but no it was
actually still there he said that when
the mom came she was like what the hell
is all this [ __ ] in your bed like how
did it get here well not actual [ __ ]
what's all this [ __ ] in your bed the
kid's [ __ ] is bad no it was like rocks
and pine cones and roaches and [ __ ] and
he was like I don't know this [ __ ] just
started like falling out of the ceiling
or whatever
um and at this point he said at this
point he thought that his mom finally
like understood that maybe something
like really weird was going on but she
didn't really know what to do about it
so he said she went out and bought a
Ouija board as you do and this was like
the late 60s so I guess it wasn't as
like nowadays I kind of feel like it'd
be like oh Ouija board you know what I
mean but back then she went and bought
one and then she he said she was trying
to like communicate with the whatever it
was like to get it to knock it off or
see what like what it was doing
um but it didn't work and as is usual in
these shows whenever you [ __ ] with a
with a spirit board as they called it
maybe they couldn't call it Ouija
because that's copyrighted by the Parker
Brothers company yeah um I think it
might be actually yeah
um because he called it a spirit board
but um so yeah so apparently like what
she did with that probably like made it
worse because that's they don't want you
playing with that [ __ ]
so um yeah so I think Anthony called
like the narrator he says uh Barbara
unleash the shadow man's Fury that's it
that's what he said that's what he said
it so I wrote it down because I thought
that was funny
so in so what happened after that was
like and actually I thought this was the
best done like the best sequence like of
this episode
because the shadow man is in the bedroom
and he like kind of starts crawling it's
he's not really crawling but he kind of
like across their bedroom wall like it
kind of like one hand comes out and one
hand comes out and then like he kind of
like goes like that and like the boys
both see it like they both wake up in
the bed they're like holy [ __ ] like as
you would because it looks like this
[ __ ] shadow man like crawling across
and then when it's over the door like it
turns its head and looks at them and it
has like these bright glowing red eyes
it's really well done it's like really
creepy like I said if I saw that in real
life I would like [ __ ] [ __ ] a brick
you know what I mean but I don't know if
that was probably not that impressive in
real life so uh so they see that
Tim runs to their parents room and he's
like scared to knock at first because
he's afraid of how his dad's gonna react
um you know and he was probably right to
be scared if I said react because sure
enough his dad gets real [ __ ] shitty
about it and he says yeah you know what
your problem is he's like it's the
Boogeyman and it's like it's doing for
you it's doing this because you're a bad
kid yeah yeah yeah if you're good then
it'll go away
that's what he basically said I can't
get like this dude in this was like
really like I said he was a little bit
over the top no he's good but they said
yeah but yeah but they they I guess they
kind of told him he's like because
you're a bad kid he's like saying it
like that which I thought was like super
funny so it's like if you're good it'll
go away and I was just like holy [ __ ] uh
so Tim said that his dad telling him
that like really [ __ ] with him for a
long time because he's like well I
thought oh I'm a bad kid and like I
deserve to be punished now but he didn't
know what he did so it like gave him
some real issues so I guess he had I
don't know it was like I was like yeah
that'd be pretty [ __ ] up if you were
seven like your dad telling you that
yeah the monster is gonna get you
because you suck yeah pretty much that's
what his dad told him
so after that happened they decide okay
well we're not going to tell the parents
anything anymore which you know
um so they're like basically what we did
was we just kind of felt like we had to
toughen up and the like whenever the
[ __ ] was in you know the shadow moon was
in the room which it seemed like it was
all the time at least the way they were
talking they would just kind of like
hide their heads under the covers and
just like hope nothing bad happened
they're like that's pretty much all they
could do because they couldn't go to
their parents because they didn't
believe them or they would just yell at
them or whatever so they said their dad
meanwhile getting just angrier more
frustrated the family is getting more
chaotic more dysfunctional and Tim
thinks like nowadays he thinks that back
then all the negative energy is like
feeding this entity though like maybe
that's what was making it worse it all
kind of fits in with Poltergeist though
too Poltergeist phenomena will can
appear that way
that you know I mean you're all this
negativity all this negativity is
feeding it you know
yeah yeah I mean and he said pretty much
that exactly right that he thought that
and he actually said something
approximating this is a little bit later
on but he said something like
approximating
um the kind of feedback loop that it
gets into where it's trying to like do
[ __ ] up [ __ ] so it'll scare you
because then it has like more more
energy negative like emotions that it
can feed on you know what I mean yeah
which falls into Poltergeist not
necessarily demonic Spirit or anything
you know
yeah I think it's Poltergeist
so on Christmas Eve which I guess this
was kind of like a Christmas episode too
like at least momentarily
uh Christmas Eve the boys sneaked down
to the living room in the middle of the
night to like look at the presents you
know what I mean like you did when you
were a kid
now uh while they're down there going
like woo look at all that [ __ ] uh then
they said they heard a bunch of banging
that started from back in their room
which they were not in at the time
and then they had there was like the uh
nativity scene like on the mantle
and it kind of like flew off the mantle
and like broke all the ceramic pieces
including broke the baby Jesus don't
break the baby don't break the bed
that's what I said don't break the baby
Jesus yeah I think it broke all the
[ __ ] wise men and Joseph and Mary and
all that [ __ ] Not only was it Jesus
it was the Baby G that makes it even
[ __ ] worse you know what's hilarious
I want it's a baby I
went on YouTube on like Christmas Eve or
something like that and one of the First
videos that it recommended to me was
like um cats invading nativity scenes so
of course I sat there and watched it
because that's going into the nativity
scene yeah oh my God those [ __ ]
pictures were so funny I like yeah just
cats sitting in the middle it's like hey
I'm the baby Jesus what's up it's like I
don't know that's why I thought that was
so funny but it was I just thought it
was funny that it was recommended to me
because I was like oh you know me so
well okay uh so yeah broke the baby
Jesus so so the boys are freaking out
because not only are they like not in
bed and they're gonna get in trouble
but their dad is going to hear all this
noise and blame them for whatever
happened you know what I mean so sure
enough uh very predictably the dude
comes down and he's like all [ __ ]
he's a rage monster it's like oh your
friend from the closet came down like
Christmas Eve and started throwing
things around that would happen is he in
the tree is he blah blah blah is he this
or that I was just like he was kind of
doing that which is like really funny
this dude this actor was like making me
laugh so um this is up there with the
dude from [ __ ] Summerwind that's what
I mean it was kind of like that it was
kind of like
but
um
I kind of almost want to like make a
make a clip of this guy going like is he
in the tree because that's like that's
the way he said that okay
friend from the closet is in the tree so
and he's and he's breaking baby Jesus
[Laughter]
[ __ ] baby
it's a little ceramic baby yeah you
leave not just Jesus it's a baby
damn that's terrible it is terrible yeah
so at this point dad says oh you want to
stay up all night you want to stay up
all night you can stay up all night
outside yeah right now yeah so he makes
the kids go outside I mean it's Florida
they're not gonna freeze to death I know
it's like winter but it's probably like
80 degrees outside they're fine
mosquitoes get them yeah they might get
yeah they might get eaten by mosquitoes
and like get Encephalitis or something
like that that's before Encephalitis
that would be like the word yeah
Encephalitis that was more like an 80s
the 90s thing I kind of feel like there
was I remember when that was going
around like but this is like oh my God
you can't like you had to go outside and
you had like long sleeves and like off
on and all that other kind of stuff so
he makes them go outside and he's like
they have to stand on the edge of the
woods like out in the yard and he's like
you just have to stand there like all
night because he's just like sick of
their [ __ ] right
so um and Tim is saying that at this
point he realizes that this entity or
whatever it is is like really
intelligent it was like specifically
trying to get them into trouble by doing
stuff that would get blamed on them so
like their dad would like
do [ __ ] to them you know what I mean so
they said that it was like something
that was like an intelligent being
so the two boys are like standing out
here by the [ __ ] tree like in the
yard it's the middle of the night and
they're trying to like keep it together
and like Tom is trying to use the older
one he's kind of like trying to be like
it'll be okay it'll be okay like for the
younger brother whatever but Tim keeps
like peeking around the tree and seeing
the shadow guy like seeing it like right
there standing to the shadow guys stand
back there and they said they could cure
him too so I guess they could hear him
like walking around like breaking sticks
and stuff so at this point they just
keep freaking out and freaking out and
then Tim like starts yelling for his mom
and then the Mom finally comes out and
it just says to the dad it's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing you can't like
make the kids stand out in the [ __ ]
yard in the middle of the night on
Christmas Eve what the [ __ ] are you
thinking so finally like the dad comes
like I guess you can come back inside
you know what I mean because I guess the
wife is like not gonna let him touch her
anymore until like eats until he behaves
so they do like kind of let the kids
back inside
so the haunting gets worse after that
point uh one night Tim's covers get kind
of like pulled down like they kind of go
shoot like that and he's kind of like
half asleep it seems like and he's just
kind of like what the [ __ ] and he like
pulls him back up I was worried about
that oh the covers being pulled off that
happened to um my mom and her sisters
and my grandma my grandfather's old
house when they were kids they said the
covers used to come off them all the
closest I ever had to that [ __ ]
was uh deer in the whole [ __ ] Mammoth
Mountain [ __ ] Poltergeist episode I
know was that my aunt Lois's house or
her apartment actually at that time
in in the guest bed which was just a
[ __ ] fold out cop a sleeping bag on
it
in Wesley's room
and it I heard the damn Wesley's dresser
drawer opened up
and [ __ ] I heard it opened up and I
know there was nobody there so I started
hiding underneath the dev I was in a
sleeping bag with a head like that I
felt something hit the [ __ ] top that
sleeping bag and I realized it was a
shirt
and it pulled it down I heard it down
the nylon of that bag down to the feet I
kicked that [ __ ] off and it did it again
Mommy
I got so scared that I passed out
I was that what scared me
woke up the next morning and every
drawer was open and the whole thing was
[ __ ]
empty and at the foot
of the sleeping bag and down the foot of
the where the uh the fold out caught was
was all of Wesley's [ __ ] clothes
it threw everything on me
that's bizarre man that is all very
bizarre because there wasn't any damn
covers to pull off but after that I
would have been worried about the covers
being pulled off because that's just I
guess it's like a typical fear did
something pulls my covers off ghosts
better not pulmonary covers up I never
did sold out but it threw things on me
while I was trying to punch that just
that one time be like [ __ ] with me
while I'm sleeping didn't do it again
though I don't like that [ __ ] that was
towards the end of the phenomenon maybe
three or four days later that was the
end of it and it ended
hey Louie Louie's here what's up good
afternoon everyone late merry Christmas
to everyone Merry Christmas thank you as
well uh Rebecca also says racing in and
racing out but I hope you all had a
decent Christmas and boxing day thank
you very much Merry Christmas and yeah
it is boxing day today not in the U.S
what's boxing day it's the day after
Christmas it's a holiday in uh Canada
and the UK and Australia
no no no I don't know I don't remember
why it's called Boxing Day necessarily
but it's just kind of they always get
the day off like after Christmas too
which is good because everybody in the
UK was like hungover okay so it's kind
of nice that you get the day off after
Christmas as well
it's kind of more of a holiday it's kind
of like I feel like in the U.S
people do more [ __ ] like on Christmas
Eve and Christmas day yeah although I
never got Christmas Eve off sometimes I
had half day on Christmas Eve but
everybody like in as far as I know like
UK Canada they get boxing day off it's
like a right like Christmas Day and
boxing day I tried to get a strawberry
out of there but I can't get I can't get
my hand in there okay I might have Drake
at all black frog said I sampled that
guy's voice in one of my cartoons when
it goes now go to bed
so I'm gonna have to like do that is he
in the tree yeah is he the tree where is
he that's good it's just the way he said
it like made me laugh and the the way
that he says about the Boogie bait it's
like a kid bad kid you're a bad kid yeah
like the way you said back we need
something made me laugh too like if I
remember I'll do it but it's like
sometimes I don't remember
um so yeah so the kids like in bed and
the like the the cover kind of comes
down and he pulls it back up but then
they like get whipped off entirely right
so Tim said he had to like reach under
the bed I guess like to get him back and
then like once he gets back in bed and
pulls the cover up I guess he's like
used to it at this point because they've
been having this shadow man like [ __ ]
with him like all this time but he said
it it was like it looked like on the
reenactment there was like a big hand
and it kind of like reached up under the
covers and started like touching him he
said it felt like somebody's fingernails
breaking across his rib cage that's what
he said it felt like and this I guess
this was the first time that it had
touched him you know what I mean so he's
like [ __ ] terrified obviously so he
just like jumps out of bed and starts
running and he smacks like straight into
the wall like I guess he missed the door
I guess because he was like Panic do you
know what I mean so he runs right into
the wall and he broke both his collar
bones
ridiculous which they showed like a
couple times like on the show just like
smacking just like this horrible sound
effect and I was like you'd have to like
hit that because you'd think just like
run it and like run it into the wall you
would break your nose or your teeth he
must have hit one side he must have
maybe
because it seems like you'd kind of have
to be going like that like to break both
of your collarbones because your face
would be jutting out but you know I
don't know
so he said he broke both his cockroach
so his parents kind of like rush in like
they initially think as they would that
like Tom was beating up on his younger
brother even though he's just sitting up
in bed gone I didn't do [ __ ] he just
like jumped out of bed and [ __ ] ran
into the wall you know what I mean what
the [ __ ] did I do so uh the kid what
is it strong
[Music]
damn you haven't you have a problem I
eating a couple of cotton balls soaked
in [ __ ] isopropyl alcohol
one of these days we'll have to get the
pickle moonshine too I'm excited to try
the pickle moonshine yeah we're trying
pickles they have a pickle one too
because I love pickles man yeah when you
get to that that's gonna be rough man
it was like
well I'll just probably I'll have like
isopropyl alcohol I'm not going to eat
the whole thing at once I'm just gonna
like take it in little like bites or
whatever
so that's all I have
[Laughter]
Tom's he's shutting that [ __ ] down oh
shut that [ __ ] down I had a big
discussion on Tom chitty movies yeah
it's awesome if me telling you to shut
it down who's shutting it down am I
shutting it out or you shutting it down
I shut it down I'm always the boss
basically they said to you shutting it
down some people said that no you gave
the order command it's like Picard on
[ __ ] Star Trek going make it so you
know what I mean yeah but I'll have
something yeah but they do it so you
know whatever that's what I mean I'm the
one doing the [ __ ]
and I could not listen to you you could
just you could say shut that [ __ ] down
and be like no good and what are you
gonna do about it nothing
just
I say it again
yeah see I'd make you shut it down
go down there and hit the circuit
breaker she doesn't know what a circuit
breaker is gonna hit the circuit breaker
turn the power off on the house I shut
that [ __ ] what are you talking about I
owned a house for many many years and
lived on my own for many years okay it's
like I don't want a [ __ ] circuit
breaker all right I love how you think
I'm dumb adults
he always assumes I don't know how to do
anything you know I thought about the
circuit break
well yeah you could do that but that
kind of be cheating wouldn't it yeah of
course that'd be cheating you're taking
matters into my own hands okay
I mean really it's not that big a deal I
don't know why you would why you want to
have to be like in Boss all the time
[Laughter]
all right I'm just letting that alcohol
seep in into this strawberry now I was
eating that [ __ ] strawberry that was
yeah it was a little well I'll I'll get
to it in a minute I don't really want to
eat it I think they [ __ ] stopped they
they soaked that strawberry and just
pure
alcohol well probably I mean that's
probably why they're gonna put it in
there because it was like whoa It's
saturated it's totally saturated
well isn't it just kind of like didn't
kids that didn't have like much money
and they were doing like the summer
parties is like Hey we're gonna like
pour a whole bottle of Everclear like
every little watermelon and a watermelon
Everclear is yeah you know watermelon
yeah yeah yeah Everclear I never did
that but I knew something Mississippi's
the [ __ ] Everclear well no that's
what I mean I knew some kids that did
yeah that's what I was like yeah that
doesn't sound and it came in a big old
[ __ ] metal can
just like it was stuck in Hawaiian Punch
Remember The Big Hawaiian Punch cans
they had this in the 80s and 70s yeah
that's what they can't that's what the
Everclear came in
yeah
and I don't know what probably still get
Hawaiian punch in the middle I don't
think you can get everything I don't
know but the Everclear came in a [ __ ]
metal can too
redneck [ __ ] Everclear did and look
man you had to be careful with that [ __ ]
yeah you had to tell people look that's
Everclear
because it doesn't have a flavor
so if you put that in punch
because that's what we're pouring it at
Hawaiian Punch
you could drink a lot of that punch and
you would get [ __ ] up and there was no
way to really get it out right you know
because it it had a kind of a [ __ ]
dry a dry dryness to it like isopropyl
kind of a [ __ ]
quality to it but you weren't really
sure how much alcohol that was
you'd go down to [ __ ] you'd go down a
wrong path real fast on that
but we got used to it
yeah just don't play with shotguns and
gasoline when you're [ __ ] been
drinking well I mean that should go
without saying but uh yeah but that's
sadly uh yeah we need to say it anyway
Mississippi and [ __ ] 14 year olds
with [ __ ] shotguns and woods and
gasoline and never clear and
and girls
and a four yeah I got pictures to prove
and videos to prove back in the 80s a 14
year old girl looked like a 20 year old
next to a 14 year old boy
14 year old boy I look like a child
but we were hanging out with him
drinking ever cleared and [ __ ]
shooting the shotguns and [ __ ] having
it listening to [ __ ]
[ __ ] like the Violent Femmes and all
that you know it's like it was a fun
time man I remember the days yeah
remember you remember those days yeah
yeah I was I was like do you remember
those days I'm only a couple years
younger yeah
Zach says uh I overheat easy when I'm
trying to sleep so if it goes pulled the
covers off me I'd just be like hey
thanks yeah pretty much I mean I have I
have one of those column fans like that
rotates back and forth and it's on my
nightstand and I have to have it blowing
like yeah on me also now I did turn it
off the last couple nights because last
couple nights in Florida believe it or
not it actually froze it was down in the
30s which doesn't usually happen
especially this early in the year like
I've never I don't remember it being
this cold on Christmas since
uh ever
well maybe not ever no but it snowed
here at Christmas before but it's very
very unusual usually it's not usually
like hot on Christmas sometimes it is
but it's usually like warm on Christmas
so it being like freezing on Christmas
was kind of like a big deal I was like
oh it actually feels like Christmas
because it's cold outside Mississippi
gives this cold about every Christmas
and what's different is that um
it's very dap here so the cold is very
penetrating it feels yeah it feels much
colder than it is so I actually slept
good like the last couple nights because
I'm like oh it's cold so I could
actually turn my fan off and like I
could actually get under the covers and
be comfortable and like cozy and stuff
instead of just constantly kicking the
blankets off because it was too warm you
know what I mean wait till you get down
to that I thought that was going to be a
nice sweet break from the drink it's
gonna that shit's gonna burn you up well
you know that [ __ ] was dry man do you'll
like it though
Zach says you still need to do some shut
this [ __ ] down merch shut this [ __ ] down
Tammy said yeah no one else would get
yeah
[Laughter]
do you understand the inside jokes I
make that but that's the fun about it
yeah we'll sell that's the fun of it
yeah that's the fun of it I'm gonna shut
this [ __ ] down well not yet I'm not done
but the thing is is that that didn't
that wasn't from me I got that from
Negan
that's where that was that's right that
was the first inspiration
I had forgotten about that because it's
been a while since we went yeah I got
that from Negan from [ __ ] Walking
Dead I'm gonna shut this [ __ ] down
and I'd be like yeah
you all thought he was a bad guy I liked
him I was like yeah he's doing the right
thing
no I wouldn't have hit old boy with a
[ __ ] Korean boy with the [ __ ] bat
uh yeah that was [ __ ] up but they were
he was trying to lay down the law and
make sure that [ __ ] he was to be
obeyed you know what I mean you're in
his territory sorry I don't like that he
was running the show
actually that was kind of like he well
they they had killed some of his guys so
you know yeah but his guys were [ __ ]
well it was an [ __ ] it was the time
of the [ __ ] you know another [ __ ]
they were just dude
okay I didn't feel bad
he's a bad guy I don't care I don't care
what you say he's a charismatic bad guy
I'll give him that
but
how'd he just kill how do you killed
some of the more annoying characters
like for example had he been the one
that killed what the [ __ ] was that
chick's name that was annoying Andrea
yeah how do you killed her hi Andrea
though I'd have been like man girls
didn't like Andrea but I liked Andrea
[ __ ] really only the first four
seasons four or five seasons were any
good of The Walking Dead we stopped
watching that [ __ ] it got too fake but
uh the first like three seasons were
[ __ ] really good survival
training survival horror type trade real
good but it just started to get too
[ __ ] it got it well a lot of them a
lot of the um kind of core characters
that I liked from the beginning were
gone I mean Daryl was still on there but
um you know after Andrew Lincoln left I
was like you know Rick's gone and then
it started to lose its realism though
too I mean they're stopping AK rounds
with [ __ ] sheet metal and stuff Tammy
said there's going to be a Negan Maggie
spin-off oh okay
um the magic's gone of that program yeah
I haven't I haven't seen like the last
couple Hugo says isn't this uh this is
funny he says you guys should watch The
Edge of Tomorrow
matter of facts we just watched it last
night and we're gonna do a review of it
tomorrow yeah it's so funny that you
should mention loved it I liked it yeah
because we were talking about that like
I think on the Sidetrack show yeah and
then last night we watched The Haunting
episode and it was still pretty early
and I said hey do you want to like watch
that Tom Cruise movie yeah um because we
still got like time and he was like yeah
so we rented it and watched it I liked
it so yeah so we'll be talking about
that tomorrow blackfrog said have you
seen Basket Case yes I've seen it many
times we have a review of it somewhere
we reviewed that a while back then yeah
yeah I thought we did all right so we're
almost done with this we're almost done
and then you can talk about whatever you
want no we'll talk about shutting this
[ __ ] down why because he's gonna get
something to eat aren't you oh okay yeah
that's right I thought you ate before
the show I did I did I didn't yeah guess
who's got it [ __ ] prepared at you
unless you're gonna prepare it no you
can do it all right
okay you got to polish off the last of
that turkey dark meat I got some of that
yeah I'm the dark meat person yeah I
like white meat too but um I got a leg
left dark meat's my favorite I got a leg
left for you okay
uh so yeah so where were we okay so Tim
breaks both his collarbones that's what
we're talking about now the kid
presumably gets taken to the hospital
they don't really show that but they
just have the mom go be like wait yeah
we should take him to the hospital I'm
like yeah you think
so after this after that happened the
episode actually jumps ahead quite a bit
so the narration says that Tom the older
one that he moved out of the house as
soon as he was old enough to get out
like us so I guess as soon as he
graduated high school or college or
whatever and that the brothers kind of
lost touch over time
so they said well Tom went and played
football for FSU which is Florida State
University in case you didn't know which
is in Tallahassee up in the Panhandle
and then later became a firefighter and
later an assistant fire chief so there
you go Tim meanwhile they said
eventually became a Paranormal
Investigator and although they did not
mention this on the show I found out by
Googling him that he is also a preacher
so you know
so in 2009 like on the show they showed
the brothers like they reunited in order
to figure out what they're going to do
with their parents house because I guess
both the parents are dead now
um you know so they both go to the house
to see like what are we gonna do with it
are we going to sell it or whatever
so Tom the older one he said it'd been a
long time since he'd been back to that
house uh because he hated it so much he
got the [ __ ] out of it as soon as he was
old enough
but that when he went in there it still
had what he called the sick evil feeling
that he remembered from his childhood
now Tim and his wife Trish they decide
that they're gonna buy the house and
live in it and kind of like try to get
rid of the entity because like I said
they're both I'm assuming they didn't
say this outright but I'm assuming that
the wife Trish was also like a
Paranormal Investigator because it
seemed like they were a team
so they're going to move in and they're
going to try to get rid of the entity
they'll try to like reclaim the house or
whatever
so Tim and his wife Trish and their
associate whose name is Roy Hall who
they say was like a violent hauntings
expert they do kind of like your Sage
your traditional like sage and Bible
reading kind of cleansing type of thing
paying particular attention to the boy's
former bedroom where most of the
negative vibe was the strongest I guess
Roy the violent haunting guy uh he was
on the show and he said that he thought
the that the entity was initially drawn
to the house because of their abusive
dad and that again like it fed on the
negative energy that it generated and it
was like a feedback loop type thing so
after the ritual that they do which they
don't really go a lot into on the show
but they just kind of like show it a
little bit
uh they said the energy like kind of
felt different although Trish did imply
that she didn't say this outright but
she implied that she thought like the
energy wasn't entirely gone right
because she said that she could still
feel something she said underlying the
house and underlying her husband as well
which I thought was a very interesting
thing for her to say
um but Tim says that her that him and uh
Trish and Trish also as a son I guess
from a previous marriage named Gabriel
and that they're like really happy there
and so that their happiness seems to be
keeping the entity from maybe getting a
foothold basically like I said they
didn't say that outright but that seemed
to be what they were implying
um and Tom the older brother who wasn't
really much interested in paranormal
stuff before is kind of more into it now
and spends quite a lot of time over
there with his brother and his family
and he said the place is a lot better
so as I mentioned uh Tim Yancey who is
the younger brother the Paranormal
Investigator he actually has a bio on
the Internet Movie Database
and this one is this is what it says it
says Tim Yancey is an actual violent
haunting Survivor and has been a real
paranormal researcher as opposed to like
uh well it got fake an imaginary
paranormal research he's a real
paranormal researcher an investigator
for over 35 years he is also an active
prayer chaplain with his church which is
Unity the Palm Beaches where he hosts
the Sunday morning Services uh he's
probably one of the most recognized and
Progressive Authorities on the subject
of violent and demonic hauntings he is
much sought after a public speaker on
the topic and is spoken at colleges and
universities paranormal conferences and
conventions around the country he has
appeared as himself in sci-fi Channel's
documentary film The Haunted boy which
is kind of interesting I haven't seen
that and his stories but also been
featured on destination America's hit TV
show haunting which is what we're just
talking about together with his brother
Tom they were both featured by Warner
Home Video in a special DVD release of
CW Network's hit TV series Supernatural
so there's that too I'd like to see the
haunted boy yeah I would as well like
yeah we should look that up because they
got the title right in a poultry guy
Christ
Poltergeist is the haunting of people in
a way not really of places
but I think I think it's rspk it's
generated by the person's subconscious
yeah so we'll see you know but
everybody's going to have their own
interpretation but you know I pretty
much know what I know
yeah
well you know certain religious
certain religious viewpoints are going
to support an a different hypothesis you
know what I mean [ __ ] demons
basically well you're going to Serious
in the framework of whatever your
pre-existing beliefs
right doesn't mean it's wrong
necessarily I'm just saying that you're
going to be that's what they're going to
do right you're going to be more likely
to see it like that uh so then it says
Tim has traveled the country for years
working with families who are
experiencing frightening paranormal
activity in their home is tough
no-nonsense method of clearing A Home of
negative energy is powerful and intense
okay and has often involved violent and
frightening attacks from negative
entities okay so that's his bio on IMDb
I don't see that he's written any books
though I did look on Amazon and I
googled and stuff like that and it's
weird because on his IMDb page it had
like a link to like official website but
when I went there it was just like a Wix
like a um like a placeholder kind of
site so it might be that he's like
working on it or he was working on it he
never published it or something like
that yeah because they're right but it's
not there well no I'm just saying the
website he probably just started because
it's Wix and that's a web building you
know site where you just go and build a
website and then you have to like pay
like once a month or whatever maybe it's
not real tech savvy who's gonna hire
somebody to do it for him but never
never happened because it's like kind of
like I don't use I usually I use Weebly
but um yeah you know what I mean yeah
contact us we'll [ __ ] with Jenny will
do it for you I mean you got to pay I'm
not gonna do it for free but you know
what I mean like I'm broken up as it is
I'm not doing [ __ ] for free yeah but uh
but yeah
so uh so yeah so he doesn't seem to have
like much of a web presence anymore but
he does have like an IMDb page but like
I said he's unlike some of the other
people that were on here he hasn't
written any books not that I could find
anyway there was another guy that had
like a bunch of Christian books on
Amazon but his name was Philippians so I
don't think it's like any relation even
though his last name was spelled the
same but I didn't find any from this guy
so uh so yeah so that's about yeah this
was actually a good episode it had like
some creepy uh sequences in it with like
the shadow guy like crawling across the
wall and [ __ ] like that that was like
actually pretty cool yeah a good episode
one of the better ones from uh Steven
season seven from what I I remember
season seven overall it was a great
Episode by The Haunting uh the case
itself seems plausible uh it fits in
some of the personal experiences that
I've had uh I believe it's probably most
likely rspk recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis I'm gonna I'm gonna go
with parapsychology not so much
spiritualism but you know what I mean
people see things and they perceive
things based upon
you know like what Jenny said [ __ ]
pre um pre-existing belief systems you
know what I mean so they're going to
want to say it's an outside force demons
uh spirits of the Evil Dead uh I'm gonna
say nah [ __ ] based on this story that
family was
eligible for what would be called
Poltergeist phenomena
rspk uh pent up emotions from uh young
kid
um fueling
psychokinesis
being managed by the the unconscious of
the subconscious in other words parts of
the brain that are not
foremost in your [ __ ] conscious
conscious sphere you know
that's what I think it was which is
that's what mine was
well because like I said this does seem
to have all the Hallmarks of that yeah
where like I said you had a real
authoritarian dad who was turmoil in the
house yeah uh spooky environment there's
a spooky woods out in the back it's
young kids they're scared they're kind
of like isolated they're isolated yeah
there's nobody else around and there's
no this is before social media they're
not sure what's real and what isn't real
and all that stuff kinda can give the
faith the fear and the faith you need
the beliefs that allow psychokinesis to
happen but it's always under the
direction of the unconscious mind
uh from my experience to do this [ __ ]
consciously that would make you a Jedi
or a Sith I haven't seen that yet
they don't need that we don't need
people being able to do that closest
thing I've seen to people be able to do
it consciously or at least in reports or
the you know like the Russian girl who
could move things move the uh
the compass needle by thinking about it
or she evidently stopped the heart of a
frog I think by thinking about it
um
I would never do such a thing I would
actually be scared if I had that ability
because like you might like stop
someone's heart by accident like if you
just thought about it like fleetingly
and then I'd be like oh my God I'm gonna
like kill people without even realizing
well operation Stargate and the military
and everything they were interested in
that
psychic assassins somebody that could
find somebody and then cause them to
have a heart attack totally deniable
they're totally deniable well yeah like
if you could actually have somebody that
could do that but I'm just like saying
you'd really have to like have a tight
handle on that because if you actually
like just hypothetically if you actually
like had that power I would be like
really paranoid that I'd be like killing
people accidentally you know what I mean
it's like if you just thought of it like
randomly like you know like your you
know wife or something like that pissed
you off one day and you're just like man
what's that [ __ ] is like I'm gonna give
her a heart attack and then I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm sorry I felt like that but then
like it was too late you already did it
you know but only was some kind of movie
I didn't see it but uh there was a movie
in the past 20 years about the unit
that's Operation Stargate was doing the
operation Stargate where there guys were
trying to will goats to die
yeah
I've never seen it but it might be a
good movie I don't know yeah yeah it is
good I saw it a long time ago they were
trying to do that with the operation
Stargate there was an army unit trying
to do that
of course as far as we know they never
willed a goat to die
they tried to but if the goats are like
why are you looking at me
but there was evidently a Russian girl
who could move needles of a compass this
is back in the 60s
and she evidently stopped a frog's heart
from beating
uh and they got now here's the thing
this is based on memory I don't remember
you know in my memories you know
everybody's memory is slightly [ __ ]
fuzzy sometimes especially you know when
you get to be as old as me the
many times on programs like on in search
of and [ __ ] like that they tried to make
it seem like that girl was
some part of some kind of KGB experiment
to make a psychic assassins and psychic
to prove psychic abilities
but I remembered later on it came out
after the fall of the Soviet Union that
that story was [ __ ] that that was
just a civilian paranormal investigator
in in Russia investigating this
phenomenon
and evidently got some stuff on film
but it it didn't have anything to do
with the with the Soviet government
evidently but see everybody see that's a
better story though yeah
like it's a lot more intriguing the
government's doing all the secret shape
yeah but evidently it was a civilian
like now it's just a random fun
it was a Paranormal Investigator a
parapsychologist that was setting this
up
and evidently it was kind of like uh
Sensational even in the Soviet Union in
the time
I remember growing up you know during
the Cold War
I was a product of a [ __ ] Military
Academy
um and we kind of had a different view
of the Soviet Union back then we thought
everything was under the control of the
Soviet government
and that everything was very militarized
and [ __ ] very worked like clockwork
in the Soviet Union but evidently that's
not the way it was well the truth is
always a lot more yeah the truth was is
that it was a lot like the United States
everything's just kind of cobbled
together
and nobody knows what they're doing most
of the time right and it was that's why
I don't believe in these big Grand
overarching conspiracy theories because
I'm like
man you can't get like five [ __ ]
people to like do anything that works
right so
much less like a whole [ __ ] world
spanning conspiracy [ __ ] that yeah what
I know now is that the Soviet Union was
like the United States but it was just a
welfare state
but it people Wanted cars and they built
[ __ ] and they did things on their own
and they made little Independent films
and they did things just like they did
here if they had the money to do it
um
so when it came to uh oh Natalia
whatever her name was who could move the
needle
that was not a government thing so
there's a chance that that could have
been faked is what I was what I'm
getting at yeah
well that's true of any of those right
but I mean it's an interesting story
yeah I mean if you really wanted to fake
it I mean it'd be much easier nowadays
obviously but it's like even if you
really wanted to fake it bad back then
you totally could yeah like if you knew
what you were doing but what was weird
is that the US government was real a
scared of that
they saw those films and tried to
respond they actually had military units
that were trying to figure out so I mean
the people that work in there they're no
smarter than like the average
[ __ ] in the street so it's like
we better do we better have a [ __ ]
psychic response we better start [ __ ]
figuring out these psychic abilities
which is kind of hilarious because it's
like if you were really smart like if
you're in a country let's say let's put
out all this propaganda that like makes
it looks like we're working on like all
this [ __ ] psychic [ __ ] and then we'll
just like point and laugh right
but one of the things about Stargate
though is that they had some remote
viewing stuff that did turn out to be
pretty accurate about uh that the
Soviets were working on typhoon class
nuclear missile submarines and stuff and
some of those remote viewers had seen
those
they were asking them what they were
building in those silos and they came
back and they said it's a big submarine
and they even drew it out
there was no way no I'd be kind of
curious to know like if that was just a
lucky guess because the thing about it
is that how much data did they
produce how what what percentage of that
data was accurate I remember it was
pretty accurate of the percentage that
was accurate
um how much of it was just kind of like
kind of a vague according like I drew
something that looked like a cucumber
and they just like uh interpreted that
cheese submarine I'm just saying I'm
just wondering Jenny's got these tight
ass black bell bottoms on right now
she's looking good [ __ ] uh anyway I
I'm gonna [ __ ] tell you why aren't
you you're so easily distracted with
this ass man but look the the my hand
this isn't down there and I know that
I'm looking at this area
that's my cat it was it was from
whatever from what I remember
according to the sources that I read
back then
they got it pretty
accurate how big the sub was how many
missile tubes it had I would like to see
the right now the thing is though is you
had to find the raw material that's what
I'm saying okay a book can claim that
those guys said anything sure uh that's
what I'm that's that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying right because
whoever wrote the book like maybe they
had an agenda an agenda or against and
so they're going to make it sound like
better than it was you know what I'm
saying what
there's a possibility of that I don't
know if that's the case in this
particular case but oh yeah yeah I'm not
just saying that's because I don't know
but I'm just saying that that is always
like something the source that I had
read got it they evidently got the
amount of the number of missile tubes
correct and the dimensions correct and
the fact that it was a submarine
which that was pretty good
yeah that's true which like I said but
if that's true but I'm kind of like I
mean we did a show did we do a show
about remote viewing I kind of feel like
we did yeah or something like that
you're right I kind of feel like I'm I'm
a statistics person though it's just
kind of like it's not enough for you to
come out and say oh like this group of
people like they uh came up with this
and they were really accurate on it I
was like yeah but
you know if you make enough guesses
you're gonna be accurate one or two
times out of all those guesses just out
of a lucky guess so it's like I'm not
impressed until you were like
uh you know 70 80 90 accuracy you know
what I mean if you like made a bunch of
wrong guesses and then made one really
really good one that is not impressive
to me that's like a lucky guess well
I'll tell you this much
Stargate did exist
they talked about it in the [ __ ]
Congress well yeah yeah pulled its
funding
but evidently they reopened it under a
different name and got that funding back
uh and changed certain things about that
so they are
interested in in psychic abilities
they believe that they exist I mean the
thing about it is that if there was any
evidence of it then you'd be dumb not to
explore that because if that was real
then yeah that could be like a big
Advantage so I'm not saying that it's
dumb to like put money into like
exploring that it's not I know it exists
I've seen it I don't know if you can
control it though that's that's the
thing and that was really what Stargate
said Stargate said yeah this stuff is
real but you can't you cannot
control it or depend upon it under the
stress of warfare
that's what I'm saying so that's kind of
like another thing it's like so it's you
know even if it exists is it practical
right in application if it's not then
it's like really not any practical use
Stargate back in the late 80s I think is
when they killed it said that they
thought the money that they thought they
didn't really save the money but they
thought that the effort really should be
put on things like [ __ ] spy
satellites and [ __ ] hard [ __ ]
electronic stuff well yeah [ __ ] that
they know actually no actually works
that this stuff does exist is it they
don't they didn't think it was it was
not reliable enough right it was too big
yeah I mean human feelings and you
couldn't predict you couldn't predict
when it was going to be right or wrong
and you couldn't depend on it all the
time and you didn't want to risk lives
on it but that but they did say it they
were saying yeah it exists but we can't
depend on it
so which like I said that's fair enough
yeah because that's the thing like
humans are complicated and mushy and we
just don't it's not the same thing as I
mean the stuff that they were wanting to
use that for would be better served by
more AI types of like technology yeah
like if you're using like humans like I
said it's very subjective yeah and like
you said you're going to be risking
people's actual lives on somebody's like
hunches essentially and it's just like I
don't think that they would want to risk
that I would not want to risk feelings
will never [ __ ] compete with
photographs and and [ __ ] infrared
data
saying yes this type of unit is located
right here at this time that's where it
is because that we know it's there right
you're right yeah that kind of it
doesn't have any emotions there's
nothing like getting in the way of it
it's just like look that's the
information right yeah it's not trying
to interpret it in any particular way
it's just showing you what it's saying
you know what I mean right so I kind of
feel like that's
so like I said I understand why they did
it you know
um because like I said if it was real
then you know that is something you'd
want to explore but
I just don't think it would ever be
reliable enough even if it was super
real like I don't think it would ever be
reliable enough to use not reliable
enough as hard hard technology right by
satellite and it's especially like not
as not very useful nowadays because we
have all that kind of stuff right
nowadays that like we don't need human
intervention for that
right as far as militaries are a person
a person could could
get an advantage but not a minute well
sure but not right military that's what
I'm saying right Ben says Grill flame
was the successor to Stargate was it
okay Grill Flame and then said when they
shut down Stargate girl flame they had a
psychiatrist make an analytical report
it was classic Mass delusion and
reinforcement yeah yeah well
they always would say that kind of stuff
it I saw a lot of the Stargate data yeah
it's subjective but it had a good
success rate
I think it was
Instinct an instinct has a lot to do
with [ __ ] Quantum Consciousness and
you're talking about Quantum stuff yeah
it had a failure rate and a success rate
I believe that yeah you probably
couldn't you you don't want to risk
lives on that yeah it's better to have
satellites [ __ ] tell you what where
something is I want some impassive
technology kind of [ __ ] I don't want a
human right but I believe that I believe
the effect was real though
that uh
I believe an rspk I've seen it
uh I've dreamed I've dreamed true I've
had out of body experiences I've had a
near-death experience all that shit's a
reality to me I would rather [ __ ]
trust satellite data than my psychic
instincts same you know what I mean I
wouldn't trust anyone's right yeah
feelings for anything like nothing like
that psychic abilities and all this [ __ ]
is always feelings and that's not quite
good enough when you're gonna bet like I
said a lot of lives very subjective
right very subjective right
I just I wouldn't risk it no I just
wouldn't now feelings me firearm a
couple of my buddies I got a feeling
that somebody's around that corner yeah
yeah like on an individual level yeah a
lot of times probably you should trust
your instincts most of the time because
they're probably right correct in this
situation I trust my feelings but on a
wider scale right probably not no
probably not we don't want to be doing
it no
uh Tom Sykes says did Tom like Edge of
Tomorrow yeah loved it oh that was good
I liked it too actually I thought it was
Tom Cruise being Tom Cruise saving the
world for [ __ ] Scientology and
[ __ ] time loops and [ __ ] that was a
good movie I know I was good I liked it
too even though I was kind of like
joking uh he kind of got on my case
we'll maybe talk about this because
we're going to talk about it we'll talk
about later but um he was kind of
getting on my case he's like quit
picking up I was like I wasn't picking
on top I wasn't literally was not saying
anything and he thought I was I just
turned right now I was just on a blue I
says I told you I'm a [ __ ] the fan
Tom Cruise I was like dude I literally
did not even say anything no he makes
good movies I want to see uh but he
always plays his he always plays Tom
Cruise he always put well he plays
himself but you're seeing the movie to
see Tom Cruise that's true just like
when you see when you when you go to see
an Arnold Schwarzenegger movie it's
because you're going to see Arnold so
that's the knee she's got right
um although I want to see [ __ ]
Maverick they're they're just starting
to stream Maverick yeah and I want to
see Maverick everybody said that one's
great yeah we'll see like I said I know
Crews can deliver
he's just got to have the right script
he's man and the the
his Ethan hot
from [ __ ] uh Mission Impossible
[ __ ] I like Mission Impossible series
real good Fallout was great I actually
liked the later ones more than the early
ones yeah yeah the later they got well
well they got more serious because they
were kind of more like well they're
pretty action adventure movies like the
earlier ones were kind of more like the
old show which was kind of like a little
bit campier which I didn't love the
early when you go back to the early ones
there were movies of their time like one
of them was a John Woo movie which that
[ __ ] was real hot in that time yeah uh
but as but when the when the um the new
James Bonds came out the Daniel Craig
James Bond they said okay we need we
gotta get some [ __ ] more like that yeah
so it became more like [ __ ] we can't
do like a fun it has to be like a series
yeah so it kind of went more the
007 Daniel Craig way which I like that
too they were all good but I prefer the
the later
the later [ __ ] mission impossible
yeah because we saw one or two of them
in the theater yeah we saw Fallout in
the theater we saw another one in the
theater
uh what the [ __ ] was that I got him I
got them all I know but what was the one
I don't think I had the brand new one I
think there was another one that came
out after Fallout I'm pretty sure we saw
two of them in the theater I can't
remember I'm gonna go in there and go
look at the Mission Impossible
uh
selection and see if there's if I'm
missing any yeah Ben was talking about
The Men Who Stare at Goats um they said
the movie was a stupid comedy uh the
book was actually quite horrifying yeah
it was based on a book uh Ben said the
whole goats thing was trying to stop
someone's heart by concentrating on them
yeah one of the goods dropped dead one
time while it was being stared at and
that Green Beret became a legend
[Laughter]
movie though I don't think that happened
in real life well it was
like a book about something that
happened did it really happen though
well I don't know I haven't I saw the
movie but it was like a long time ago
and I wanted to read the book but I
don't think I ever got around to it
you're gonna eat look look Jim I know
try it okay I'm gonna have Jan try the
[ __ ] strawberry yeah well wait a
minute it's just kind of like there's
all this ice in the way that you can
handle that
you can handle it now it's like Should I
stick my hand stick your head in there
get it all right
you tell me what that strong somebody
said okay I'm not gonna eat the whole
thing though no you've put the whole
[ __ ] in there
oh dude
it's like hot what well it's not hot
it's just
it's like it's been an isopropyl alcohol
kinda how did that happen
I mean it kind of you can still tell
it's a strawberry though like it so it
has a very very strong strawberry flavor
but it also is a very very strong
alcohol
flavor
it's not bad you just well you have to
like kind of I'm not gonna put the whole
thing in my mouth
[ __ ] man
[ __ ]
yeah it's dry it is
God damn
there
somebody used to like gift that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Zach is cracking up oh my God man
it's a lot
it's a lot
it's like eating a damn it's kind of
burning my tongue yeah it's like a
[ __ ] it's like drinking isoproflo
alcohol
it's kind of like the cotton ball that
they wash your skin injection
now I'm kind of wondering what the
pickle one will be like I don't know
I'm still kind of curious uh the pickle
one was not is not is not moonlight
it was that was that was old that was
old smokey oh smoke oh Smokey seems to
be
not as [ __ ] alcoholic and uh a little
more flavorful that [ __ ] there is
[ __ ] just
that's that that's artificially flavored
that's the Moonshine that's the real
moonshine
that was that was definitely
picture
um what a strawberry soaked in moonshine
would taste like and that's pretty much
exactly what it tastes like
it tastes basically it just tastes like
a strawberry
oh soaked in like pure alcohol you're
dinosaurs are [ __ ] yeah but it really it
I will say though even though it does
kind of like burn your tongue it does
like it enhances the strawberry flavor
it is very strawberry forward you guys
know the strawberry corgis where you
have the [ __ ] Brandy inside of it
imagine yeah imagine you put crack in
there
have you ever tried crack no I was gonna
say I mean it wouldn't surprise me if
you had never tried correct no you've
had I would never smoke crack you've had
cocaine yeah it's not a cocaine but I've
never smelled crack
you talking about I haven't either
Jenny do it again this is fun
I don't eat all the strawberries that's
it that's it oh my God it's Monday night
I gotta get up and work tomorrow Yeah
tomorrow's not gonna be as cold either
oh yeah that bums me out I like cold
weather
I just like I'm sitting here in my
office my little jacket on it's awesome
and it's Christmas time and it's cold
just like it's supposed to be right now
it is
44 degrees go ahead and hit that like
button people go ahead and please hit
the like button looks like a lot of
people have go ahead and checked out
because they're like oh that's the
show's over yeah there's nothing now
they're eating alcohol strawberries go
ahead and shut this [ __ ] down yeah we've
been on more than two hours you wanna uh
you want some turkey yeah okay I'll make
some turkey that sounds good all right
we're gonna make some turkey so you guys
we're gonna be back tomorrow talking
about a movie like I said we're talking
about Edge of Tomorrow uh because one of
you guys uh nominated that like
recommended it so we watched it last
night so we're gonna talk about that
tomorrow the Tom Cruise movie uh so yeah
hopefully you guys can drop by for that
and uh thanks for dropping by today
thanks for super chats if you gave us
some and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow good night